.
Thank you.
Okay.
All right.
Good morning.
I think it's a good morning.
Welcome to the executive session, Wednesday, House resources recreation and development committee first I'd like ask you to rise and we play bridge of allegiance representative Crichton would you lead us in the pledge to the flag of the United States of America and to the republic for which it stands, one nation, under God, indivisible, with liberty and justice for all.
Thank you very much.
We might as well move right into the business.
The committee opened the hearing, or excuse me, opened the executive session on House Bill 1167, establishing a maximum containment level, contaminant level for perfluorinated chemicals in surface water.
Chair recognizes Representative Kelly for a motion.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I'd like to make a motion of interim study on House Bill 1167.
Thank you.
Do I have a second?
Second.
Second by Representative Perez.
Thank you very much.
Before I ask you to speak on the motion, Representative Smith, can you introduce the people you have brought for substitutions?
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
We have Representative Marty Jack sitting in for Representative Spang and then Representative Maria Perez sitting in for Melbourne Moran.
Welcome to the committee.
Glad you could come.
Representative Kelly to speak on your motion.
I think that from what we heard, DES is Thank you.
could come.
Representative Kelly to speak on your motion.
I think that from what we heard DES is bringing forward their MCL for fluorinated carbons and surface water.
So I think that interim study will give them time to finish their work.
But I think there were a number of issues raised by this bill and by the other bill about surface water that could use our work at a later time possibly.
Thank you very much would you like to speak to your second?
No.
Is there anyone on the committee who wishes to speak to the motion?
Motion of IS or interim study.
Seeing none, on the motion of interim study for House Bill 1167, will the clerk please call the roll?
Thank you.
Representative Harb.
Yes.
Representative Gould.
Representative Corrigan.
Yes.
Representative Creighton.
Representative Dodge.
Yes.
Representative Creighton.
Representative Dodge.
Yes.
Representative Healy.
Representative Mayville.
Yes.
Representative Post.
Representative Smith.
Yes.
Representative Perez.
Representative Grassi.
Yes.
Representative Gotland.
Representative Cohen.
Yes.
Thank you.
Representative Renzullo.
Yes.
Passed unanimously.
Consent?
Pardon?
Yes.
Any objection?
The bill will be on consent.
I will close the hearing, or excuse me, I will close the executive session on House Bill 1167.
I will open the session on House Bill 1185.
Representative Healy for a motion.
I'd like to make the motion with ought to pass with amendment.
A motion of ought to pass with amendment.
And the amendment is 0583H.
0583H.
I would like, Chair would call Representative Rung, who was put amendment 0583H.
These are small businesses that serve residents that are on a septic system.
Following that hearing, I met with Representative Mr.
Natch-Graise from the New Hampshire Municipal Association and Ms.
Rita Croce, who is the Deputy Director of the Merrimack Wastewater Treatment Facility, to address those concerns, because we did feel that that was a shortcoming in the original bill.
So we worked together to produce the Amendment 0583, and I want to point out the changes in that amendment from the original bill.
One, New Hampshire Municipal Association added a statement of findings and purpose, just to establish really what the intent of this legislation would be.
So you'll see on line 20, that's really, that's going to be the same as what you saw in the original bill.
But then back on line 14, what we've done is distinguish between private septage haulers that serve residential units versus those that serve any commercial or industrial purposes so it's allowing wastewater treatment facilities they may collect if they feel they need to samples for PFAS from septage loads originating from residential sources so it makes that distinction between the residential septage haulers and other ones.
Non-residential septage loads from commercial or industrial sources shall have prior approval by the municipality before discharging to a wastewater treatment facility.
That statement refers, in a way, back to a new line on line 9 of page 2, where the Merrimack deputy director really wanted to make clear that municipalities that do not have wastewater treatment facilities have to enter into agreements with other ones, and those agreements have to be honored.
So let me give you an example.
Let's say Brookline does not have its own wastewater treatment system.
They contract with Merrimack to accept their waste.
Merrimack has to accept that waste.
They can't deny it.
But with this amendment, Merrimack may test that.
They don't have to refuse it, but they can test it so that they can understand the PFAS coming into their site.
I hope I made that clear.
I'd be happy to answer any questions.
Any questions on the amendment by members of the board?
Representative Cohen, then Representative Crichton.
Mr.
Chairperson, I just want to second Representative Healy's motion to make this legal.
Thank you.
Thank you for correcting me.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Thank you for correcting me.
Thank you very much.
Representative Creighton for a question.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Representative Rugg, I appreciate your efforts to do this.
I just want to make sure I understand, based on the last testimony that we had.
As I read this, it says a wastewater treatment plant may require any industrial or commercial facilities or septic haulers.
So then it's up to the wastewater treatment plant to decide whether the septic haulers are tested.
So if I'm a septic hauler and I go to three different houses and I pick up all their stuff and I go to the plant, it's up to the wastewater treatment plant to decide whether they charge.
Remember the discussion about, well, we've got to wait for a day and we don't know when it's going to happen and which house it came from.
There was all that.
That's still in here.
It's still in here that if the director of the wastewater treatment plant wants to arbitrarily Thank you for your comment.
With septage haulers, there are those that service industrial commercial customers.
So there's different ways that waste can enter wastewater treatment system.
It can come by industrial commercial that are discharging into a sewer system, but it can also come from industrial commercial that are contracting with a private septic hauler.
This amendment distinguishes those septic haulers from the ones that go to homes to pick up waste.
For instance, in Merrimack, we have a car wash that hires a septic hauler to take away its waste.
We're distinguishing that from the septic hauler who comes to my house to pick up my waste.
We're treating them the same.
So if a septic hauler is bringing industrial commercial waste, they would be subject to having that waste tested.
And if it's very high in PFAS, for instance from a car wash, they could be regulated.
haulers are different so it would put the it would put a responsibility on the wastewater treatment plant to identify if a septage coming into the plant is from a residential source or manufacturing industrial source.
It's distinguishing between the types of septage that are privately hauled and brought to a wastewater treatment plant.
For a follow-up, sir?
For a follow-up.
Can you explain how it does that?
You lost me.
I've got industrial commercial facilities.
I understand that.
And then septicolers.
Those are the only two categories that I see in here.
There's not a residential versus a commercial.
On line 14, on page 2, that's the due language that distinguishes septage loads originating from residential sources.
They may collect, but they wouldn't be held to the same standard as manufacturing industrial sources that come either from a septage contractor or through the wastewater treatment system.
Okay.
Okay, thank you, ma'am.
Okay, thank you.
Any other questions concerning the amendment?
Representative Harb.
Thank you, and thank you for taking this comment or question.
Representative Rung, I heard what you said about line 14, but like my fellow rep, I'm a little confused because line 23 that says they may require a septic collar to test, and then I look at line six on the second page.
They may refuse a discharge from a hauler that has levels.
I'm getting the impression that if a residential analysis is made and he exceeds the PFAS level, under page two, line six, they can refuse to take is septic.
Is that true?
I think that is the reason why.
Well, thank you for your question.
I think that is the reason why line 9 on page 2 was included, that if the wastewater treatment plant is in a contract to accept municipal septage from another community, whether it's high in PFAS or not, they have to accept it per that contract.
This does not supersede the contract they have with municipalities, but it does empower the wastewater treatment facility to request testing so that they can understand the PFAS load coming into their system, knowing that they can't control that residential septic that's under the contract with other municipalities.
Thank you.
And I should say, too, that when we were discussing this amendment, Ms.
Croce from Merrimack did reiterate strongly it's important for them to know how much PFAS is coming in, even though some of it may not be regulated if it's under contract from another municipality.
but it allows some predictive data for what may end up in their compost or discharged into the Merrimack River.
Any other questions?
I do have a question.
I'm just trying to get my hands around what exactly is happening to the residential septic collar.
The way the things seem to be written, we're talking about line three on the page two, an industrial or commercial facility or septic hauler.
It doesn't say or commercial or industrial septic hauler, it just says septic hauler.
That could be a residential.
I'm not certain what protection the residential septic hauler has that from having to treat or having to analyze their load.
Am I making myself clear on that?
Yeah, I think, well, thank you for your question, Representative Renzullo.
I think we have to understand that not all septic haulers serve residents, that many of them, and it could be the same septicolor, may service car washes, painting companies.
They're not restricted just to residential loads.
If they do bring a residential load into the wastewater treatment plant, they are not held to testing or regulatory standards that they would under the previous section.
If they're under contract with the municipality and that septic collar on that run is bringing in residential septage, the plant has to take it.
The plant has the opportunity to request a testing.
Ms.
Croce said it could be once a year.
We just want to understand, is there PFAS in residential septage?
But septic collars, regardless of if they do serve residential, if they bring in industrial commercial waste through their septic, there is the expectation that it may contain PFAS, and they would be subject to this.
So it really is the nature of the septage that's coming in.
And the clarifying language, including the language on Line 9 about RSA 485-A, is really just to establish the fact that wastewater treatment plants cannot reject septage when they're under contract from a community to accept that waste.
Representative Connors, did you have a question?
Just a comment.
Is this just a matter of grammar, where a comma is or is not?
That may very well be true.
Do you have an English expert here that could tell us whether there should be a comma there or not a comma there to include?
It's a little more than comma.
It's just maybe an addition of a better definition or a more specific, instead of saying, for instance, an industrial or commercial facility or an industrial or commercial septic hauler, hauler when hauling commercial or industrial waste.
That's what I'm saying.
I think it's a language.
Right.
And I think it's that's, yeah, as Representative Creighton, is that kind of your feeling?
I mean, listening to your question, you're kind of in the same ballpark.
Yeah, sure.
That it's the definitions are not specific enough or the delineations aren't specific enough.
So that we don't want to have the residential septic hauler having to go and check his tank and wait three weeks before they can dump it, that type of thing.
Mr.
Chairman, would the committee be – I'd be happy if you wanted to recess this.
I can run to OLS and have an amendment that in line three, it would say an industrial or commercial facility or hauler of industrial commercial waste that receives a notification from wastewater treatment plant, you know, blah, blah, blah.
So wherever there's septic hauler that would be under the requirement of testing, I would specify it would be septic collar of industrial commercial waste.
And I believe that's in line three, but I also see it is occurring in line seven.
Representative Harb.
Thank you, Representative Rung.
In response to your inquiry, I think if you were to word search septic collar, because it comes in in line 24 and other places, I would be receptive personally to pass an amendment that identifies wherever you see septic collar, septic collars of industrial or commercial waste.
That way you've limited what the facility can do.
Then you still keep your line nine, and then you can have other things.
So I think personally that would be an amendment that I could support.
Okay, so let me run over to OLS and come back with a new amendment.
So whenever septic hauler is specified, it's specified to the type of waste that they're hauling.
I'll see you soon.
Thank you.
I think I will recess this session until she's able to come back and go on to something different, something else.
I am recessing the executive session on House Bill 1188.
House Bill 1188, establishing a commission to study OHRV use in the state.
Chair recognizes Representative Smith.
I make a motion of ought to pass.
Representative Smith makes a motion of ought to pass.
Representative?
I'd like to second that.
Seconded by Representative Egan.
And do you have an amendment?
Yes, I'd like to move amendment number 0582H, which everyone should have on their desks.
And there's a couple of extra copies on the side table over there for members of the audience, but I think there's only two or three of them.
It's very similar to what I handed out last week.
Would you like to speak to your motion for the amendment?
Why, surely.
Am I speaking on the amendment or the bill as amended?
On the amendment.
All right.
So last week during the public hearing, I passed out a draft that I had put together with ideas for changing the membership somewhat from what I had originally introduced on the bill.
And so here it is in official form.
I clarified that if I go to the membership and compensation, which is the gist of the amendment, the legislative members I broke out so that it's very clear that there are four members and not five, because it sounded to some people like there were five members.
So we tried to clarify that.
And then we removed from the original bill that the director of New Hampshire Parks was on.
We removed him because in speaking with Director Bryce, he told me that the chief supervisor for Bureau of Trails was enough and that they're in constant communication, so he would be learning all about what was happening from him.
And then I removed the sheriff and put in one representative of municipal police departments appointed by the New Hampshire Association of Chiefs of Police.
And let's see.
Oh, and then I added the one member representing landowners appointed jointly by the New Hampshire Timberland Association and the Farm Bureau.
And the word jointly kind of makes it clear that there's only one member there.
And then the one representative from New Hampshire Auto Dealers Association appointed by the association is added, and that is because they represent those who sell OHRVs.
And then we have one member representing the New Hampshire Society for Protection of Forests, the Appalachian Mountain Club, and the Nature Conservancy.
And these people all have a lot to do with land use and conservation.
But it's one person and they are appointed jointly.
And the word jointly kind of makes it clear that there's only one member there, appointed jointly by those organizations.
And then one representative of the New Hampshire Rail Trail Coalition appointed by that coalition.
And I had a lot of requests from a few different people on that one and then two members of the public one of whom appointed by New Hampshire Association of Conservation Commission's and one appointed by the North Country Council which is the regional planning Commission for the whole North Country from Plymouth going north and that is what the amendment is and does.
Thank you, Representative Smith.
Representative, was your first motion ought to pass or ought to pass an amendment?
Whatever is the legal way to do it.
Oh, okay.
I was just, if it was, well, just to be certain, on the amendment, I presume you are...
I just spoke on the amendment.
You're moving the amendment.
Yes.
And I would second the amendment.
Yes, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you.
Would you like to speak on the amendment, Representative Egan?
I think it was well thought out.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Any questions or comments on the amendment?
On the amendment 0582A?
A2H.
Seeing none.
On the amendment 0582H, will the clerk please call the roll?
Harb.
Yes.
Representative Huff.
Representative Gould.
Yes.
Representative Horgan.
Representative Creighton.
Yes.
Representative Dodge.
The clerk votes yes.
Representative Healy.
Yes.
Representative Mayville.
Representative Post.
Yes.
Representative Smith.
Representative Post.
Yes.
Representative Smith.
Representative Perez.
Yes.
Representative Grassi.
Representative Gottling.
Yes.
Representative Cohen.
Representative Connors.
Yes.
Representative Vail.
Representative Kelly.
Yes.
Representative Jack.
Representative Egan.
Yes.
And we're...
Representative Vail?
Yes.
Representative Kelly?
Representative Jack?
Yes.
Representative Egan?
And Representative Renzullo?
Yes.
Passed unanimously.
Consent?
That was just on the amendment.
Does anyone wish to speak to House Bill 1188, ought to pass as amended?
Representative Smith.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
As I said at the public hearing, this bill came out of many past pieces of legislation that have been heard by this committee having to do with OHRV and their expanded use presently in New Hampshire and all over the country, actually, and how some of our statutes are out of date and everything's been put together piecemeal.
And a group of stakeholders met in August representing the OHRV industry, fish and Game, sheriffs, state police, legislators, and a lot of other people.
And the idea proposed by Executive Counselor Kenny was that we needed a long-term commission.
And so I began working on that, and this bill is the result of that.
The bill will last up until the election in 2026.
I didn't want it to be any shorter because I really wanted to give the Commission time to do their work, but I didn't want it to extend past that election in November 2026.
I ask you support.
I worked with a lot of stakeholders on this, and I thank them.
Any other one?
Anyone else wish to speak?
Representative Egan.
I think this commission is essential because it equally balances the interest of the industry as economic development and tourism, but also respects the points of view and gets input from landowners and homeowners, and I will be supporting this piece of legislation.
Anyone else wish to speak to the motion?
Representative Vail.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I'm speaking in support of the bill as amended, and I'm just really glad to see this moving forward.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I'm speaking in support of the bill as amended, and I'm just really glad to see this moving forward.
I hope that everyone will vote in favor of it because the five-year commission is really the way to go with trying to sort out a lot of the problems that we've been having and move ahead.
So thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you.
Anyone else wish to speak on the motion?
If not, on House Bill 1188 with Amendment 0582H, will the clerk please call the roll?
Yes, thank you, Chair.
Representative Harb?
Yes.
Representative Huff?
Representative Gould?
Yes.
Representative Horgan?
Representative Creighton?
Yes.
Representative Dodge?
The clerk votes yes.
Representative Healy?
Yes.
Representative Mayville?
Representative Post?
Yes.
Representative Smith.
Representative Spang.
I mean, okay, I'm sorry, I didn't do this one.
Yeah, that was Representative Perez.
Yes.
Well, see.
Okay, go ahead.
It's on the notes here that says who's replacing who.
I'm sorry, Perez votes yes?
Yes.
Okay, thank you.
Representative Grassi.
Yes.
Representative Gottling.
Representative Cohen.
Yes.
Representative Connors.
Representative Vail.
Yes.
Representative Kelly.
Representative Jack.
Yes.
Representative Egan.
Thank you.
Connors.
Yes.
Representative Vail.
Representative Kelly.
Yes.
Representative Jack.
Representative Egan.
Yes.
And Representative Renzulu.
Unanimously passed 21 to 0.
Unanimously passed.
Consent.
Seeing no objection, it's on consent.
All right.
House Bill 1227.
Open the hearing on 1227.
Relative to the definition of prime wetland, Chair recognizes Representative Huff for a motion.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I move that HB 1227 is rendered an expedient to legislate.
I'd ask for a second, and I'd like to speak to my motion.
Do we have a second?
Representative Creighton, second.
Representative Up, the floor is yours.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
On this bill, in testimony, we heard from numerous organizations from the state as well as private that were against this bill.
Primarily because of the definitions, it would make it very, very difficult and cause costs, unforeseen costs and delays in pertaining basically to our highways.
And for that reason, that's why I would like this to be ITL'd, and I ask that you support that.
Thank you.
Representative Creighton, speak to your second.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I think it was said very well thank you anyone wish to speak to the motion representative grassy thank you mr.
chairman and I'm sorry I couldn't be here when this bill was originally heard but and I'll keep it as brief as possible I think one of the comments that was just made is this will have additional cost to our highways if it's passed.
And there is an exemption in here to basically exempt DOT from work that they're doing within the wetlands.
But let me get back to the primary thing.
And one of the comments that was made during the testimony was that this, since they changed the rules to take out the supposed fingers and toes of a wetland that we haven't had any problems.
Well yeah they haven't any problems because they're there basically haven't been any new wetlands approved by any community since then.
Under current regulations I mean you can't really do a lot within a wetland anyway.
It's very restrictive building within a wetland.
It's these fingers and toes, which are the sensitive areas, that communities need to take a look at when they're concerned with erosion control, when they're looking at sediment going into major water bodies, when they're looking at contaminant filtering, when they're looking at flooding in their communities.
And communities that would consider this are communities which are basically have critical concerns within their towns or cities.
Communities just don't adopt this.
There's a major criteria that have to be taken a look at.
And it's reviewed by local and state as well before a community is approved for a prime wetlands.
And one of the things is that this is not a bill which is just going to automatically affect everybody in the state.
This is a bill which is a local option, basically.
It says that if you have a reason and a need to protect certain smaller portions of a wetland, which the main wetland is already pretty much protected, it's these smaller portions, then you need to go through the process, have it mapped, to have it identified, and to make sure that it meets the criteria for adoption as a prime wetland.
A local community will then have a vote of its town.
Under the bill, the planning board that is doing these hearings are required to take into consideration the landowners that are involved and impacted.
And it's something that's not taken lightly in communities just for the fact that even prior to this, not a lot of communities adopted prime hotlands.
Only those communities that felt that it was needed in their community.
And I would hope that this committee would vote in favor of it.
This has passed the House and the Senate previously, was vetoed by the governor.
This bill was worked out in a bipartisan way in the conference committee, the wording that we have here before us today.
It does exempt DOT from work because I know a lot of work that they do within wetlands and within other areas in the state.
Sometimes it's a critical need.
It's an emergency.
So we've taken care of those things.
It's the developers who basically are going to go in and damage these wetlands that communities want to take a look at before they do to make sure that their concerns are addressed to make sure that they're not impacting flood storage of those areas or the ability to filter out contaminants are not impacted by these building within these areas or development with these areas and I would hope that the committee would would pass this and that we could send it to the the full house for consideration thank you so I vote no on ITL anyone else wish to speak on the motion?
Seeing no one, on House Bill 1227, the motion of inexpedient to legislate, will the clerk please call the roll?
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Representative Harb?
Yes.
Representative Huff?
Representative Gould?
Yes.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Representative Harb?
Yes.
Representative Huff?
Representative Gould?
Yes.
Representative Horgan?
Representative Creighton?
Yes.
Representative Dodge?
Clerk votes yes.
Representative Healy?
Yes.
Representative Mayville?
Representative Post?
Yes.
Representative Smith?
No.
Representative Perez?
Representative Grassi?
No.
Representative Gotling?
Representative Cohen?
No.
Representative Connors?
Representative Vail?
No.
Representative Kelly?
Representative Jack?
No.
Representative Egan?
And Chair Renzullo?
Yes.
Kelly no no no yes 11 to and motion fails what motion what?
Motion failed?
Passed.
ITL.
We're not putting this on consent, right, Mr.
Chairman?
I'm not.
I would.
No, that's all right.
No, I don't think so.
I don't think so.
I will have the minority report for you this weekend.
Thank you.
And I will write the majority report.
How do I, after four to five times, how can we make it any different?
You did the minority report the last time we actually dealt with this bill.
That's right.
Okay.
I will close the hearing on House Bill 1227.
Representative Egan, you do have some bills that are coming a little bit later.
Would you want me to move them forward?
I know you have...
Yes, they're delayed at that other committee.
Would it help?
Would it...
It would.
I want to be able to admit that I will move them forward.
You're so kind, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you.
On House Bill 1498.
House bill 1498 establishing a safety program for off-highway recreational vehicles and snowmobiles.
Representative Egan, I recognize you for a motion.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I move for this bill to go to interim study, and I'd like to speak to my motion and ask for a second.
Do I have a second?
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I'll be succinct.
In working with the industry and the Fish and Game Agency, there is a little bit of work to do on this bill to help refine costs to the riders, and that is why I think a study would require us, within a short amount of time, knowing the study would need to be completed by November, that I'd be able to work with Fish and Game, with the industry, with law enforcement to refine the concerns that folks have about the costs of safety training program to the riders.
And I want to respect that.
Therefore, I ask for it to go to interim study and thank you.
Representative Kelly to speak to your second.
I think that safety is an issue that we should be dealing with but at the same time it's a very tricky subject that we need to balance different competing interests.
So I think giving us time to talk with the parties involved and work towards a bill that works for everybody would be a good idea.
Anyone wish to speak or have a comment or speak to the motion?
Representative Smith.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
And I wanted to add to that that since this is a complicated issue and we have just passed House Bill 1188, that any work that is done, if it hasn't come to its finale conclusion by November, that that work can be adopted by the Commission to help solidify the safety plan.
Because we know that there have been a lot of accidents this year.
I know I passed out a handout on that.
And many of those accidents are due to inexperience of riders.
And so this safety program is really needed, both for snowmobiles and OHRVs.
Thank you, Representative.
Is there anyone else who wishes to speak on the motion?
Seeing none, motion on House Bill 1498, motion of interim study.
It's tough to swallow.
Interim study.
Will the clerk please call the roll?
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Representative Harb.
Yes.
Representative Huff.
Representative Gould.
Yes.
Representative Horgan.
Thank you.
Yes.
Representative Huff.
Representative Gould.
Yes.
Representative Horgan.
Representative Creighton.
Yes.
Representative Dodge.
The clerk votes yes.
Representative Healy.
Yes.
Representative Mayville.
Representative Post.
Yes.
Representative Smith.
Representative Perez.
Yes.
Representative Grassi.
Representative Gottling.
Yes.
Representative Cohen.
Representative Perez?
Yes.
Representative Grassi?
Representative Gottling?
Yes.
Representative Cohen?
Representative Connors?
Yes.
Representative Vail?
Representative Kelly?
Yes.
Representative Jack?
Representative Egan?
Yes.
Representative Renzullo?
An interim...
Okay, read it down.
21 to 0.
Consent?
Unanimous.
Consent it is.
And that's it for 14...
I'll spill 1498.
You still...
They are actually back on schedule, so can I do one and run yep I would you're so kind mr.
chair Gonna move move back to pass.
Ought to pass by Representative Gottling and seconded by Representative Connors.
Representative Gottling, you wish to speak to your motion.
Thank you.
You may remember when we considered this bill with this new and unusual method of having fun on the water and the fact that it is classified as a boat at present, And it really needs to have safety and all kinds of specifications made for it.
And we need to give Marine Patrol the authority to write the rules that will pertain to having this boat operate safely for everyone.
Do you wish to speak to your second?
Thank you.
I just want to state that the current classification as a boat does not meet the needs of this new craft, and as Representative Gottling says, we need to move forward with some more requirements and safety protocol for this.
Does anyone wish to speak to the motion?
Seeing none on the motion of ought to pass for House Bill 1316, will the clerk please call the roll?
Thank you yes yes yes yes yes yes.
Representative Healy.
Yes.
Representative Mayville.
Representative Post.
Yes.
Representative Smith.
Representative Perez.
Yes.
Representative Grassi.
Representative Gotling.
Yes.
Representative Cohen.
Representative Connors.
Yes.
Representative Vail.
Representative Kelly.
Yes.
Representative Jack.
Representative Egan.
And Representative Renzullo.
Yes.
That's 20 to 0.
You name is the past.
Consent?
It's consent.
It is on consent.
All right.
We'll open the hearing, close the hearing on 13th.
the here close the hearing on 1316 and open on House Bill 1440 I'll spill 1440 relative to surface water quality standards for perfluorinated chemicals.
Chair recognizes Representative Creighton for a motion.
Thank you, sir.
I move HB 1440 for interim study.
Do I have a second?
Second.
Second by Representative Harb.
Will you wish to speak to your motion, Representative Creighton?
Yes, sir.
The HB 1440 brings up an important point, which is protecting the waters in New Hampshire.
Department of Environmental Services is charged with that task and has a study ongoing with imminent results to that study which will cover the chemicals associated in HP 1440 so I move interim study to allow the department to complete a study make its recommendations and take care of the health and safety of New Hampshire citizens.
Thank you.
Representative Harb to speak to your second.
I echo the comments of my fellow representative, and I think a study is required and would be of great assistance for this very important bill.
Thank you.
Anyone else to speak on the motion?
Representative Smith.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I just wanted to add that in testimony, DES spoke that they are working on developing the rules for these, the PFCs in surface water, and that the rules will be out in the next couple of months, and they are in review now.
So hopefully we won't have to do too much because they will have done the work before we have a chance to.
But yes, I support the interim study.
Anyone else wish to speak on the motion?
Seeing none on the motion for on House Bill 1440, the motion is interim study.
Will the clerk please call the roll.
Thank you Mr.
Chair.
Representative Harb.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Representative Harb?
Yes.
Representative Huff?
Representative Gould?
Yes.
Representative Horgan?
Representative Creighton?
Yes.
Representative Dodge?
The clerk votes yes.
Representative Healy?
Yes.
Representative Mayville?
Representative Post?
Yes.
Representative Smith?
The clerk votes yes.
Representative Healy?
Yes.
Representative Mayville?
Representative Post?
Yes.
Representative Smith?
Representative Perez?
Yes.
Representative Grassi?
Representative Gottling?
Yes.
Representative Cohen?
Representative Connors?
Yes.
Representative Vail?
Representative Kelly?
Yes.
Representative Jack?
Representative Egan?
And Representative Renzula?
Yes.
Unanimously passed 20 to 0.
Passes unanimously.
Consent?
Say consent it is.
All right.
Close the hearing on House Bill 1440.
I'd like to actually step out of order because House Bill 1554 is Representative Egan's bill, and out of courtesy he is prime on another bill and another committee at the moment, and he is testifying at that.
I feel out of courtesy I will skip over and let him finish where he's doing and he'll come right back here.
I'd like to go on to House Bill 1602.
First, I will not be taking any motions on this.
I'd like to discuss it a bit with the committee.
In our caucus this morning, we had some questions that went beyond the amendment.
I'd like to be able to have a work session on this to see if we can work that out.
We do have executive sessions on the 23rd, but the afternoon is open.
So I'd like to be able to schedule a work session for this to work out those questions if possible.
And we will also, at the time, also schedule it for exacting no matter which way the work session works, how it works out.
That's my plan.
I'd like to, obviously it's my right as chair to do it, but I think I do want to also get general consensus among the committee that it is the right thing to do.
It would be, oh, Mr.
Chair?
I think it would be good to know what the concerns are because the amendment does make it so that schools and child care facilities, the only ones who would be required to do the testing would be those that are not on a public drinking water system.
And then also, as DES had requested, it also makes it so that the water is tested at the source, not at the individual faucet in the building.
So if we knew what the issues were that we're going to study, and we might have to get someone in here to help us out to figure it out, that would be good to know.
Yeah, Mr.
Chair, thank you very much.
The major concern on here was where it says under line 21, public and private schools and licensed child care facilities shall within 30 days compare the results results and if they don't meet those standards then get a new test and the question is who's paying for that new test there was some confusion or whether DS just comes and does that or whether that is then incumbent upon those facilities to get that test and then the cost of the test.
I know, I just wanted to make sure that we knew what we were doing in terms of putting an onus on those companies to do that.
So I think it's the right thing to do, but it was just unclear who's paying for that.
Does that answer your question, Representative?
Yes.
Not to say that between now and then, we had to think of some more.
I know I was going to suggest we ask Ted Dears to fill us in, but he has stepped out.
Oh, Brandon Kiernan's here.
That's good.
Mr.
Kiernan.
Thank you.
I'm Brandon Kiernan.
I'm the administrator of the Drinking Water and Groundwater Bureau at DES, and we had submitted a letter of testimony for this bill.
One incremental option could be, and we offer this in our letter, is that there's about 150 entities that aren't testing for PFAS right now.
All the other schools, child care facilities are addressed.
Is there're either public water system or get their water from public water system but there's about 150 in the next 18 months with our own staff and our own funds the bill would require the facilities to test every five years for three five-year periods perhaps we just see what this initial data says.
I can summarize the existing data for the public water systems for these facilities and share that with you.
We have that in hand.
And then within 18 months, we'd have those private wells.
And then once you see that data, you could see if it really made sense to keep testing every five years for the next 15 years after that.
Of course, you're not volunteering to do it for the next 15 years, are you?
No, we have funding for the next 18 months.
The funding expires, so that's why we offered to do one round in the next 18 months.
But then you would have data in hand to see if you think it's necessary to keep that requirement ongoing or not.
You could assess based on some information.
Okay.
Thank you.
Any other questions by any other members of the committee?
Just as a question of order, the motion was, or you were suggesting that we continue this, but I hear Mr.
Kiernan saying he needs 18 months.
How does that work into anything we might do with this bill?
Because we don't have 18 months to study this bill or do anything with it if we wait for his results.
I think we could achieve a shorter time frame.
18 months is just the window.
We have funding.
We do have a backlog of private wells, a sample.
We have hundreds we're trying to do in southern New Hampshire because of contamination.
But we could try getting the majority of those 150 sampled in the next few months, potentially.
Right now, it's voluntary, though.
We have no authority to enter their premise and collect samples, and some of them really hesitate to take on any more sort of discretionary assessments than they have to because they already are burdened with a lot of other things.
So it's not a guarantee we'll get access to all 150 sites thank you mr.
chair thank you mr.
Karen I'm sorry I didn't see you hiding in the back there would we need to amend the bill further to stipulate that DES would cover the first round of testing, in your opinion?
No, we're prepared to do the work.
I mean, it's totally the committee's discretion if they want to pass a law to require us to do it.
But I can commit to you that we'll make an effort to sample those 150 over the next several months.
Again, several of them may decline that opportunity.
And also we can summarize the data for the other 750 or so entities that we already have data for, the schools and child care facilities, so that for the work session you'll have some information to see the wisdom of making this an ongoing requirement or not.
Thank you.
Representative Grassi.
Yes.
Would requiring, would passing this bill give you more power as far as testing all the wells, you said, because some of them may not comply with testing?
Would passages of this bill, basically making it mandatory that they be tested, give you more authority to go in and test those wells?
It would give us the authority to require those wells to be tested one way or another.
The entity could still decline us doing the work, and then they could do it at their own expense.
But, yes, as proposed, it would be required.
The testing would get done one way or another.
That is correct.
Any other?
Representative Cohen.
Thank you for taking my question on this.
So if we pass this bill today, would the department need for this year or next year to raise additional funds somehow or be funded additionally to make this happen?
Are you saying if we pass this, you have the funds for this year and next year all ready to do this?
The legislature already allocated a sum of money to do PFAS investigations Thank you.
you have the funds for this year and next year all ready to do this.
The legislature already allocated a sum of money to do PFAS investigations.
That money is available for the next 18 months.
So we have adequate funding to sample for the next 18 months for those 150 private wells.
Thank you for the clarification.
Seeing no further questions, thank you.
Rather than rush forward, I think it's easy enough to have our work session, talk it out, and hopefully come to a consensus.
Because I think there's a lot of value in this bill.
I know.
So I'm going to withdraw House Bill 1602 and we have a work session on it and also we will be executing it on 223.
We have a, we will be, I will be adding that to the executive, excuse me, the execing list for that day.
right.
So right now we have only 15 54 and that is Representative Egan and also we have 1185 Representative Rung is bringing in an amendment.
So I call a recess until one of those individuals shows up.
Then we'll start the hearing again.
So Selva, I can save 10 minutes.
No, no, I saw them.
Yeah.
Okay, well.
Thank you.
Call the executive session to order for House Bill 1554.
relative to online payment of fees and fines relating to the operation of off-highway recreational vehicles and snowmobiles.
Chair recognizes Representative Egan for a motion.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I'd like to make a motion to pass House Bill 1554 with an amendment, Amendment 0548H, which you have received.
And I'm glad after a second to speak to both.
Okay.
Do I have a second?
Second by Representative Gottling.
Representative Egan, do you wish to speak to your motion?
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
What this bill does is basically enabling legislation allows the Fish and Game Department to be able to offer online registration for snowmobiles and OHRVs, allows them to to build that infrastructure and optionally be able to figure out then in their own rulemaking how to execute that and the amendment removed and optionally be able to figure out then in their own rulemaking how to execute that and the amendment removed fines because as we heard in testimony Fish and Game was concerned that they would have to work with the courts to figure out revenue distribution and a lot of other aspects that would make this bill more complicated than trying to help Dealers get vehicles OHRVs and snowmobiles registered allow fish and game to put the process online so we can have better data that could be used for it and That's why the amendment exists is to make the bill much more streamlined Oh, your amendment is 0548H.
No, this is 27.
I got 0274.
Oh, OK.
Just all right.
7 4 oh okay just alright you wish to speak to your second representative let's keep it to the amendment first you're fine?
Okay.
All right.
Any questions on the amendment?
Representative Harb.
Representative, thank you for maybe taking this question.
My memory, and it's only my memory, was that Fish and Game had suggested renewal fees, not initial registration fees.
Is there a reason why your amendment didn't say renewal fees?
Yes.
So in talking with the attorneys at OLS, the idea of giving more flexibility for Fish and Game to have rulemaking authority in the future if they decided that they wanted to include new registrations in an online process if we did if we just specified renewal then there would potentially have to be another bill created in the future more legislation to say you can register your new vehicles so that's why it just says establish any procedures that may be necessary to enable online payment of registration fees.
So you may still have to go into a dealer and register your new vehicle and verify your identification and your VIN numbers, And you could do that paperwork there.
You could potentially pay the fee online later, but it allows flexibility for the agency to do so.
And that's why renewal was not specifically called out.
But the key for me in this amendment is that fines were what complicated it for tickets or violations and that we were just trying to streamline the process to make it easier on Fish and Game to register snowmobiles and OHRVs and make it easier for folks that have them to register online as opposed to burden retailers where they might normally go for all their goods before they go out and not have to hold up the line trying to register a new their snowmobile or HRV.
Representative Creighton for a question.
Yes, Mr.
Chair.
Would it be possible to get Captain Eastman to testify on this just to verify that they have the same reading?
Absolutely.
Captain, could you come forward?
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
When I testified earlier about renewal, I didn't want to be disingenuous or unclear that that's our intent, that this program would start as a renewal program.
program.
Now certainly between now and 2025 when this comes into effect that we would have to have something in place if technology had evolved where we could dot our I's and cross our T's and make sure all that happened certainly we would be you know amicable to all of that.
So we're satisfied with how the amendment looks.
So just to clarify for me, I'm from Hudson, I'm kind of thick.
It's that you're satisfied that within rules, you can go in either direction if you wanted to.
You could say we will not do a, you will do, you will only do renewals.
You can limit that without going, being contrary to the ordinance, to the statute.
Yes, we would establish this all in rules and that we would be able to do renewals.
If that were to change in the future, yes, we would be able to change it within rules and then go from there.
Thank you.
Representative Huff for a question.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you for taking my question.
My question is, and I'm trying not to make this the hearing, you already have administrative rules making authority.
You already take in money, either by check or cash or however you do that.
Why do we need a law that says you can still do it at just a different avenue?
I'm not understanding.
If you have the authority to take in money, why can't you just make the rule to take it in via internet?
I wish it were that simple.
Unfortunately, this would kind of is what we need to do or an impetus to get those who need to get this moving, if that makes sense.
Representative Egan, a question for Captain Eastman.
And Captain, this does not preclude allowing retailers to still take registration live and it just creates an additional way for registration to take place online say for folks that might be out of state but if someone is still the local person that wants to go down to the local dealer and see their friend and register the machine it still allows that local relationship with their dealer or or agent to take place correct that's correct it's never our intent to get rid of registration agents or anything of that nature just to bring it online so that they would make it easier for our constituents thank you thank you very much.
I haven't seen any other questions.
Anyone wish to speak on the motion?
First of all, to speak on the amendment.
Anyone wish to speak?
Okay, by the way.
On the amendment of 0548, will the clerk please call the roll?
On the amendment of Representative Harb?
Yes.
Representative Huff?
Representative Goulds?
Yes.
Representative Horgan?
Representative Goulds?
Yes.
Representative Horgan?
Representative Creighton?
Yes.
Representative Dodge?
The clerk votes yes.
Representative Healy?
Yes.
Representative Mayville?
Representative Post?
Yes.
Representative Smith?
Representative Perez?
Yes.
Representative Grassy?
Representative Gottling.
Yes.
Representative Perez.
Representative Grassi.
Yes.
Representative Gottling.
Representative Cohen.
Yes.
Representative Connors.
Representative Vail.
Yes.
Representative Kelly.
Representative Jack.
Yes.
Representative Egan.
Representative Renzullo.
Yes.
20 to 0 unanimously passed.
on the amendment.
Yes Yes On the amendment Unanimously passed now on the motion ought to pass as amended will the clerk please call the roll Representative Harb?
Yes.
Representative Huff?
No.
Representative Gould?
Yes.
Representative Horgan?
Representative Creighton?
Yes.
Representative Dodge?
The clerk votes yes.
Representative Healy?
Yes.
Representative Mayville?
Representative Post?
Yes.
Representative Jack?
Representative...
Representative Connors?
Yes.
Representative Vail?
Representative Kelly?
Yes.
Representative Jack?
Representative Egan?
Yes.
And Representative Renzula?
Okay, that's 19 to, I mean, yeah, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, four, five, six, seven.
20 to one, yes.
Consent?
Any objection?
20 to one?
No minority report.
Only I do stuff like this in my early days.
Okay, that takes care of that now going we'll re it's start the thing to reconvene the the hearing on the session executive session on House Bill 1185.
Representative Rung was fixing the amendment.
Do you have copies coming?
Do we have any more copies?
Oh, here we go.
I guess they're coming this way.
They're coming this way.
There you go.
Does everybody have a copy of the amendment?
And the amendment is 0623?
Correct.
Okay.
Pardon?
Did we have, did we take the previous – Cohen.
Okay, but is it – it was just an ought to pass?
Oh, we haven't adopted the previous amendment.
Well, I'm not certain what the motion was ought to pass or – I think with amendment.
Okay, it was ought to pass with amendment.
Thank you.
Well, you know, I'm not certain what the motion was ought to pass or – Okay, it was ought to pass with amendment.
Yeah, we should withdraw the – Withdraw – Pardon?
Pardon?
It wouldn't hurt to have everybody withdraw the amendment.
Yeah, we'll just – To make it clear.
All right.
without objection we are withdrawing the previous amendment.
What was it?
058341.
Oh, 3H.
Okay.
Withdrawing the amendment 0 5 8 3 H.
Any objection?
If not, we'll vote on it and then get rid of it.
All right.
Looking for a motion to adapt Amendment 0623H.
Moved by Representative Connors.
Who second?
I'll second.
Representative Healy.
This is on the amendment.
He's speaking to the amendment.
Thank you very much, Mr.
Chair.
Also, for the record, my name is Rosemary Rung.
I'm a representative for Hillsboro 21, which is the town of Merrimack.
I want to thank the committee very much for their comments earlier this morning about some of the shortcomings of the previous amendment.
It's a very popular amendment day at OLS, so I apologize for not getting here sooner.
But after discussing this with the drafting attorney, we made four changes to the previous amendment.
And this is in response to your concerns about differentiating between septic collars that are unloading waste from a residential source compared to those that are bringing waste from a municipal or manufacturing source.
So you will see on line 24 on page one the term septic collars of industrial or commercial waste.
We've also made that distinction on line 27 of page one.
And on page two, line three, and also on page two, line 7.
Those are all the occurrences where septicol, or that term was used to describe the mode of waste going into a wastewater treatment plant.
I'd be happy to entertain any questions.
Any questions?
Representative Post.
Yes, thank you, Mr.
Chair, and thank you for taking my question.
In line 15, on the back side, it says wastewater treatment facilities may collect samples for PFAS analysis from septage loads originating from residential sources.
So that doesn't define the commercial industrial aspect, so they are still required.
Well, I know it's a may, but it doesn't define.
The reason that line was put in is the wastewater treatment facility has to take that waste when it's under contract with the municipality, but they want to be able to track the level of PFAS coming in.
So they may want to just get a baseline of the PFAS of that septage coming in in order to be able to predict how much may end up in their compost, in the case of Merrimack, or biosolids that would be discharged into a water body.
So just for a follow-up, please.
For a follow-up.
Therefore, these folks will not be turned away from thank you.
Correct.
Any other questions?
Representative Harb.
I just have a comment.
I want to thank the representative for bringing forth this amendment.
It does meet the concerns that I had addressed earlier.
Thank you.
Thank you very much, Representative Harb.
And I concur.
Anyone else?
Questions on the amendment?
Seeing none.
On the amendment, 0623H, will the clerk please call the roll?
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
On the amendment, Representative Harb?
Yes.
Representative Huff?
Representative Gould?
Yes.
Representative Horgan?
Representative Creighton?
Yes.
Representative Dodge?
The clerk votes yes.
Representative Healy?
Yes.
Representative Mayville?
Thank you.
Representative Creighton?
Yes.
Representative Dodge?
The clerk votes yes.
Representative Healy?
Yes.
Representative Mayville?
Representative Post?
Yes.
Representative Smith?
Representative Perez?
Yes.
Representative Grassi?
Representative Gottling?
Yes.
Representative Cohen?
Representative Connors?
Yes.
Representative Vail?
Representative Kelly?
Yes.
Representative Jack?
Representative Egan?
Yes.
Representative Renzullo?
21-0 unanimously passed.
Okay.
Consent?
That was on the motion.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, 21-0 unanimously passed.
Okay.
Consent?
Oh, was that on the amendment?
Yep.
See what happens when you're just raring to go.
All right.
On the motion of ought to pass as amended for House Bill 1185.
Will the clerk please call the roll?
Representative Harb?
Yes.
Representative Huff?
Representative Gould?
Yes.
Representative Horgan?
Representative Creighton?
Yes.
Representative Dodge?
The clerk votes yes.
Representative Healey?
Yes.
Representative Mayville?
Representative Creighton?
Yes.
Representative Dodge?
The clerk votes yes.
Representative Healy?
Yes.
Representative Mayville?
Representative Post?
Yes.
Representative Smith?
Representative Perez?
Yes.
Representative Grassi?
Representative Gottling?
Yes.
Representative Cohen?
Representative Connors?
Yes.
Representative Gottling?
Representative Cohen?
Yes.
Representative Connors?
Representative Vail?
Yes.
Representative Kelly?
Representative Jack?
Yes.
Representative Egan?
And Representative Renzullo?
Yes.
21 to 0 unanimously passed.
21 to 0.
Now, is it consent?
Seeing none, it is consent.
I will close the executive session on 1185 and the rest.
All of them.
We are finished.
Okay.
Now, before we go running off, It's want to make certain on who's on board for the blurbs.
The committee reports, no, no, the blurbs.
This is Representative Gottlieb.
Oh, I'll do my bill.
Okay, you're on the 13th, well, I'm just going to go right down the list.
Representative Kelly.
Okay.
Representative Healy for 1185.
1188, Representative Smith.
1227 is myself and Representative Grassi.
All right.
Going right down.
1316, Representative Gottling.
1440, Representative Creighton.
1498, Representative Egan, and Representative Egan on 1554.
And we have to get, and 1602, we just, I have to set up a work session.
Okay.
That's it.
See you at 1 o'clock for the moorings.
Rob, seconded the last motion.
Connors moved it, made last motion.
Connors.
Oh, for the...
Moved it, made the motion.
Seconded the last one.
For the last...
No, that was on the...
Thank you.
We have a piece of paper for everything we do.
This one, now this is a work session, so it comes on a different piece of paper, as opposed to the hearing, which comes on a different sheet of paper, and the executive session, which comes on a third type of paper.
But anyway, we're having a work session on House Bill 1438 relative to the use of moorings by persons other than permit holders.
We have had a hearing on this bill.
And toward the end of the hearing, we found out that the issues really revolved around moorings on the seacoast, and not moorings on lakes.
Turns out they're under different jurisdictions, which everybody said, what?
So our committee researcher researched it, wrote a report for us on it, and got us in touch with Ms.
Marconi, who is, you'll have to give out your title, sir.
But, Mr.
Marconi, if you could come up and talk to us about moorings on the seacoast.
Identify yourself and your title, sir.
Good morning, Mr.
Chairman.
Good afternoon, Mr.
Chairman, members of the committee.
For the record, Gino Marconi, I am the director of the Pease Development Authority Division of Ports and Harbors, affectionately known as the New Hampshire Port Authority.
By statute, RSA 12G, which is our enabling statute, we are responsible for the permitting and management and the placement of moorings in the tidal waters.
And so those tidal waters are from the Massachusetts border to the main border, three miles outside the Isles of Shoals, and up the estuaries like to the dam in Exeter, the dam in Newmarket, the dam in Durham, and the dam in Dover.
And in those tidal waters we permit upwards of 1,500 moorings.
But with those moorings, the demand is greater than the areas.
So all of those procedures for moorings and wait lists are set forth in the Code of Administrative Rules, which from time to time we amend as necessary.
Thank you.
in the Code of Administrative Rules, which from time to time we amend as necessary.
This subject of the use of moorings, other than by the permit T, has been a subject that has come up many times over the years.
And the last time that it came up, at the time, it was Senator Fuller Clark who introduced some legislation.
And after some lengthy discussion about it, that piece of legislation required the Port Authority to establish a program for the temporary seasonal use of moorings.
And what that did was, and she used herself as an example, she and her husband are avid sailboaters and they would go down the coast of Maine at the time and their mooring was unused.
So what she proposed was, and this is what we did through administrative rules, to set up this program.
If you was a mooring holder, we're not going to use your mooring, and you wanted to make it available for someone else to use, you would notify the Port Authority, and then in accordance with our waitlist regulations, we would go to the first few people on the wait list and say, there's a mooring available.
It's only available for one season.
Are you interested in it?
And so through the administrative rules process, we set that up.
You couldn't go back and use it more than one consecutive year.
Any individual could not use that mooring more than one season.
I'll say it that way.
During the discussion in the committee hearings over that, one of the questions that was raised by the senator on the committee was, and I on the committee was, and I remember this very vividly, it was Senator Barnes, and he was sitting there, and he said, so I have a boat.
He says, and my buddy over here, Senator Odell, has a mooring.
And he says to me, Jack, you want to use my mooring?
And I say, sure.
And so because I'm friends with him, I get to go ahead of the 500 people on the wait list that have been waiting on the wait list for years about that.
And so that's why the language was amended in that, and that's why we went in under the direction of the legislature and set up this temporary seasonal mooring use.
Moorings are a very emotional issue.
We post the wait lists on the website and believe me people, if there's any change in that wait list position, we get phone calls because sometimes doing data entry, it doesn't always come across what's actual.
We're in the middle of the mooring reapplication period now.
And people are coming in because it's a treasured privilege to have a mooring in the tidal waters.
So I don't know what else I can say about the subject.
We get a lot of phone calls in the course of the summer from someone who will say, I'm sitting on my mooring and, you know, John, it has the mooring next to me.
Thank you.
We get a lot of phone calls in the course of the summer from someone who will say, I'm sitting on my mooring and, you know, John that has the mooring next to me, he's not there but somebody else is on the mooring.
So if we have an asset available, we'll send one of the harbormasters down and look into it.
And if there is a boat that is not permitted to that mooring, we'll tell them that it's not acceptable.
But there's a lot of coast including the moorings out at the Isles of Shoals that we're responsible for and we've got a small force that is out there managing that.
So I'd be glad to answer any more questions if you want more details on the process.
Chair's privilege.
Just as a clarification, you have now a...
a, someone can have a, if they're going to be gone they will tell you they will tell you or your organization that they're going to be gone and you will put someone else on that mooring from a list.
And so it isn't like somebody else can, they can't choose somebody.
It's whoever's on the next one on the list for X amount of time.
That's correct.
The way the administrative rule is is that we go to the wait list and make it known but I have to tell the committee in the number of years and I don't remember how many years it's been we have never had a mooring permit holder come to us and say, I want to make my mooring space available.
And we've never had anyone ask us about it.
We are not in the business of managing private property.
We are only in the business of permitting the use of submerged public land.
The mooring block and tackle and equipment belongs to the individual.
And we went through these scenarios in the discussion.
So we put person A and person B together.
Now how they arrange the use of that mooring is between them.
Person B may say, I'll pay you and use your block and your tackle.
Person A may say, oh no, no, no, you're not using my gear, you bring your own gear, which is a substantial investment.
These are questions that came up when we were working through these things.
Something that we're separated from, we're not involved in any personal business arrangements between player A and player B.
We just know that player B was next on the wait list, it It was offered to them, And whatever arrangements they made with the permit holder, we would issue them a permit.
But I just say that it's never happened.
And the rules are still on the books.
And if someone came to us, we would certainly follow the administrative rules and making those available.
Thank you.
All right.
First, Representative, you wanted to speak first?
Thank you for taking my question.
You answered part of my question.
The other question that I realized from what you said, the person who takes it for one month, is that person put at the bottom of the list or does he still stay at the top of the list?
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Sir, thank you for your testimony.
Just in the bill, it's more limited.
It's not for the whole summer, so it's 30 days max.
And the person that is permitted gets to choose who picks it, gets to choose who uses the mooring.
Do you foresee a problem with that?
If we pass this, would that cause consternation among the list of people on the waiting list?
Or how do you think that would be handled?
I don't think there's any doubt in my mind or the staff's mind that this opens the door up for abuse of the mooring.
One of the things that we're very diligent about down there is the illegal renting of moorings, falsifying of documents for someone who, you know, presents themselves as a boat owner and using a mooring that is not, the two pieces don't match each other.
We think that this is an opportunity for abuse and for rental of moorings that are beyond our control.
Yes, sir, for a follow-up.
So from your perspective, this bill would not be helpful in that there is already a system in place that could be used if bone rotors wanted to let the harbor master know that they were going to be gone for a month?
Yes, sir.
sir okay thank you thank you mr chair and thank you mr marconi for taking my question the temporary seasonal use of moorings program and the wait list is on that program?
No, the wait list is for all moorings.
Okay.
And the legislature and the jail car agreed that to be fair to the people on the mooring wait list who have been waiting, that if a mooring comes available, we would go through a process of notifying.
The rules say we'll notify by certified mail the first five people on the wait list.
We give them ten days to respond.
If they respond no or they don't respond, we go to the next 10 people on the wait list.
That's how we do moorings.
And so that would be the process we would use if someone did come to us and want to be part of the seasonal temporary permit program.
Thank you.
And so I think I heard you say that no one has applied to do the temporary seasonal.
No one has come to you and said, I'm going away for the summer.
Someone can use my mooring.
That's correct.
No one has ever done that.
If I may, Mr.
Chairman, I believe that a big part of that is the liability involved in it.
And this is one of the things that we instruct our harbor masters.
Unless it is an emergency with immediate threat to life, limb, property.
Do not ever tell anybody, go hang on that mooring because if you're on that mooring and the condition of the mooring below the water is inadequate for that boat, that boat breaks loose, what's the liability of it?
If we tell them to get on the mooring, then we're responsible for it.
If you're the person that has the permit and you allow somebody else to go on your mooring, there's a liability there unless there's a contractual agreement between you, which is something that we don't see.
So I think from what I've heard and understood from the voting public is the individuals have a concern over liability of letting somebody else use their private property, which is the block and the ground tackle.
Thank you.
Thank you for taking my question.
Yes, sir.
I'm looking at the bill, and I'm thinking there's an unintended consequence here, and I want to know if it's a way you can enforce it if this happens.
I don't think this was the intent of the bill.
But if I own a home in the Seacoast area, and I use an Airbnb-type type situation and I don't say included is, you know, you're going to pay $75 extra a day because you're getting a mooring, but as part of the rental of that home for whatever period of time, mooring use is included, is there a way you can enforce that?
A way you'd know?
Sure.
Thank you.
Is there a way you can enforce that?
The way you'd know?
Sure.
In 2001, when the Port Authority was merged administratively with Pease, we had to go in and rewrite all of the mooring regulations because Port Authority's admin rules did not transfer.
And then at the time, there had been changes in the processes and forms of admin rules.
So we went in, and before we even put pen to paper, we had several public outreach.
We mailed out to all of the existing mooring and wait list people that were on the books, invited them in to give comment on issues that they would like us to address.
So one of the things that we did do, we structured different types of moorings.
We have commercial use moorings, commercial for hire moorings, and in those categories...
structured different types of moorings.
We have commercial use moorings, commercial for hire moorings, and in those categories, a property owner can, if the use of the mooring has something to do with the business that he runs on the shore, he can come in and have his mooring declared a commercial use or a commercial for hire mooring if it's associated with a business.
That being said, once you deem a mooring a commercial use mooring, you have to year to year demonstrate that it continues to be used as a commercial use mooring.
And then furthermore, if I may, Mr.
Chairman, a commercial mooring is the only mooring in the system, the mooring permit in the system, that's transferable.
Because what we heard and what we saw was that over the years since the mooring program was put in in the 60s, that there had been a decline in commercial use of commercial activities in some of the harbors because everyone on the wait list was a pleasure boater.
And the commercial fishermen, they just, they don't think that way.
So that's why we established the commercial use boring so that we could flatline any decline in commercial activities in our harbor and it's maintained that way.
So, you know, if Mr.
Jones passes away and Mrs.
Jones is a surviving spouse and she wants to sell the lobster boat and the traps and all of the business, she has the ability to sell that equipment and that mooring permit can be transferred to the buyer if they meet certain criteria.
So the long way around to your question is if someone had a rental property, and and this even applies to condominium associations, they have the ability to have a commercial mooring that they could rent out or allow someone to use.
Thank you.
Representative Post for a question.
Anyone else?
Raise your hand and I'll put you on the list.
Representative Post.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair, and thank you, Mr.
Marconi, for being here today.
I just wondered, for the seasonal mooring use for non-commercial, how many would you say folks take advantage of that?
are there people that are aware that they can do that yes I believe there are and like I said I mean there was there was when we do administrative rules or changes to them we send out notices public it's all public notices and as I said said, moorings are a very emotional subject.
People watch what goes on very carefully.
So to the best of my knowledge, people know about it, and we've never had any requests for it.
So would you say how many people use a temporary or non-commercial moorings during the season?
Do you have any idea what turns over?
No one does.
There's been no demand, no questions, no asked about it.
No one's applied for it.
No one's come to us and said, I want to make my mooring available it's just I don't know why thank you representative Huff thank you mr.
chairman and thank you for being here and helping us understand this my question is a little bit more basic I'm just not quite clear on this point.
Somebody gets a mooring.
I'm curious as to the actual ownership of that mooring.
And by that I mean if I get a mooring, how long do I have it for and what do I have to do to keep it for is that term?
The mooring permit is issued for one year, April 1st to March 31st.
There is a reapplication period which we send out, the statute says, or the rules say, on or before January 15th, we will send out the pre-printed mooring reapplications to the current permittee.
The application with its required documentation and payment has to be received at the Port Office no later than March 1st.
There is, however, a 10-day late filing period, and it's 10 business days, so that can extend down to March 15th.
For them to provide the application, the application fee, and then they have to show proof of ownership of the vessel.
So in New Hampshire, the only way you can do that is by providing a boat registration.
So it comes in, everything is time-stamped when when they open the mail or someone comes in in person and then the administrative assistant she reviews it and if you're standing there she'll go through and say wait a minute I need it you didn't put your boat registration oh I left it in the tag out in Atlanta we'll make a copy of it so that they can complete the transaction.
Then that's put into each box for each of the individual harbors.
So we hire harbormasters in the local harbor, and they're usually people that are from that area because they're more familiar with the constituency.
So down in Hampton Harbor, our harbormaster, you sit at his dining kitchen table, have a cup of coffee, he's got a glass window, he's looking right at the harbor so he knows everybody.
So he'll take the permits in his area and he'll go through them and double check.
Make sure that the proper documentation there and look to see if there are any issues that are outstanding with the permit applicant.
Excuse me.
Then he'll sign off on it, and it goes back to the main office, and the chief and the deputy chief harbormaster, they'll take another second look at it, and if there's something that they flagged they'll talk to the local harbormaster then it's put it in the database and the mooring the mooring permit is issued to the applicant.
So basically every year it's theoretically a new owner or a leasee, I guess, even though it might be the same person.
Okay.
Yep.
Thank you.
If I may, Mr.
Chairman, we refer to it as a reapplication.
It's not a renewal because of a couple of court opinions that we went through way back in the day that the Superior Court said that these individuals that have the permit do not have a property right.
It is a permit for the use of the submerged lands of the state of New Hampshire.
Any other questions by members of the committee?
You do?
Thank you, Mr.
Chair, and thank you, Mr.
Narkoni, for taking my question.
How often do these moorings turn over?
Because I'm trying to clarify this.
I don't know anything about it, and I've been trying to read.
It doesn't sound like they ever do.
This is a season pass that someone owns public property for as long as they darn well please, and the other folks that are on the waiting list are going to have to wait until they expire or remove their boat from their registration.
So is that what I'm hearing?
I'm trying to get an idea on what this means for this waiting list people.
They use the public property for as long as they reapply.
That's correct.
We do track on a year-to-year basis, again, going back to the first time we went to court over it.
And we looked at it and we tracked each year how many mooring reapplications were sent out, how many were returned by March 1st, how many were returned during the late filing period.
How many of those are shorefront property owners?
Because by statute, a shorefront property owner is exempt from a wait list, so they can apply for a mooring directly in front of their property as an extension of their property line.
We have a line in that Excel sheet that says how many people have voluntarily given up their mooring permit.
People will call us and say, I'm out of the boat business.
My mooring is going to be available.
I'm not going to renew it.
We know how many people have passed away.
And then we have a bottom line that we don't, they did not reapply.
We don't know what happened to them.
They may have moved out of town.
So those are the ones we know are going to be available at the end of the permit season.
However, we do get people that come in that are willing to take a mooring in a location that does not have a wait list.
Somebody came in and they wanted a mooring in the marsh behind Odeon Point it's not a desirable area but you know a young lady came in she had a small sailboat and she wanted a place to put it so she didn't have to launch it all the time and up behind Odeon Point by the golf course where there's no water at low tide, she was happy with that.
So it's examples like that that are less desirable places.
When you get into areas that are very desirable, for example, Rye Harbor, the person number one on the wait list down here has been on the wait list since 1993.
My wife was on the wait list for 19 years before she got a mooring and it wasn't in a very desirable place and then it was a couple of years later that another wait list spot that she was on that was actually close to the dock that my sister and I owned that we could keep a skiff at.
It was happy time.
But can you imagine what would have happened if, you know, oh, yeah, go ahead, here's a mooring for you over here.
I would have 500 people that would burn my garage down if that ever happened.
One of the, if I may, just one last comment, Mr.
Chairman.
One of the things that the staff, and we all discuss this during our staff meetings, especially with mooring permits, we go on the perception that one of these days, the Attorney General's office is going to walk through that door, and they're going to say say I want to see Tracy Shaddock's mooring profile and that better have a piece of paper from the day they were on the wait list to the day they were offered a mooring how they were offered the mooring a copy of the certified letter the original application every year that they reapplied for that morning permit because it happened in my predecessors and if there's one thing I learned from the legislative budget assistance audit division that did a 2000 year 2000 audit I keep that audit on my desk just to remind me don't let that happen again thank you for for the opportunity to give a little commentary there, sir.
Representative Cohen for the second time.
Thank you for the opportunity.
Yes, just for the record, for this bill, are you taking a position for or against this bill either way?
To take a position on this bill is a policy issue, Representative, and the policy is set by the PDA Board of Directors, and they have not discussed this because this just, as you know, came up recently.
So I'm here to answer questions.
My personal opinion is the director is, and I would give this advice to the board, is this would open the door for abuse of the mooring permits, and it would adversely affect the people that are on the wait list.
Thank you.
Yes, sir.
Anyone else for questions?
Just thinking whether I should have another question, but I think I'll pass.
Thank you very much.
I think we all appreciate your coming in.
I think we I appreciate your coming in.
I think we all appreciate your coming in and enlightening us on an area that we know very little about.
It's my pleasure, and thank you for the opportunity to talk about the Port Authority.
And if you ever have any questions, please don't hesitate to reach out to us.
That's what we're here for.
Thank you.
Thank you, sir.
Thank you, members of the committee.
Thank you.
Members of the committee, by the way, just Representative Tarosian has passed in an amendment concerning his bill on 1438, which basically encompasses now the moorings in the shore, in the harbor waters.
Anything else that we want to just, you know, this is a work session.
it was just to collect additional information I've got a few additional minutes I think I will just let Representative Tarosian just for just for a few minutes if you wish to speak to your memo or your amendment just because Thank you, Mr.
Chair and members of the committee.
Yes, as the chair said, when the bill was drafted, it used the wrong RSA in there.
This amendment cleans it up to be the appropriate reference.
If I may, I'd just like to say that I think the Director and I are talking about something slightly different.
different.
What the intent was and what you heard when I testified on this bill prior was to allow permit holders to make their mooring available to people when they're going to be away traveling.
So in other words, a lot of boat owners travel up to Maine or down to the Cape or Islands, and their mooring may be empty for two weeks or a month.
To be clear, and I testified this before, it never said, and the intent was not for it to be a paid situation.
It was a non-paid use.
And you heard the director say that there aren't many people on the waiting list.
The intent of this legislation is not to undermine that.
And you heard that people don't take advantage of that.
If you have a vessel that's not a trailer boat, you're not going to put it in for two weeks or a month.
There is your summer mooring.
If you have a boat that size and you don't have a mooring, it's either not going in the water or you have a mooring someplace else.
This is practice in other states, in many other locations where sale clubs, of which I'm a member of one, does a list.
You put down the mooring you have, and you let membership know if it's going to be vacant.
And as I said before, I've observed and many people have told me that many of these moorings, I've seen it myself, sit empty most or a lot of the summer.
The intent of this was to take a resource that's underutilized at that point and make it available to allow voters to use that resource, come in and visit the state, and spend money.
It was a good economic thing.
It's a little bit different than being on the wait list and say, I want to use it for part of the summer so just for a point of clarification I think we're talking about something slightly different there you know you take any questions if the committee has any any questions thank you thank you that's it for our work session.
And we'll start the hearing on 1071 in five minutes.
Thank you.
Representative Gottling, you will be the presenter of the bill.
Okay.
I'm trying to get separated for how many?
Four.
Okay.
I'm looking at four.
I got four and against.
And I'll try to.
Yeah.
All right.
I'm going to call the hearing to order.
I'm going to, the chair calls Representative Gottling to introduce the bill.
Thank you.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman and committee members.
I'm Representative Sue Gottling from Sullivan District 2, representing Sunapee and Croydon.
Thank you for the opportunity to present HB 1071 relative to wake surfing, a bill that, like its predecessors, has generated many enthusiastic responses from the environmental community and the recreation community.
First, I would like to make clear that this bill is not a step toward banning wake surfing and the boats that create the wakes for this activity.
Second, I believe that those who favor HB 1071 agree with those who oppose it, that ramping up education of the boating public and firm enforcement of boating rules are important components of protecting New Hampshire's water bodies.
In fact, the efforts of wakeboat dealers to promote the Wake Responsibly campaign is contributing to boater safety and increased respect for one's neighbors on and off the water.
Despite this campaign, however, as you may know, concerns and problems remain, and this was made even clearer by the host of emails that you have been receiving.
At my last count, there were more than 200 in favor of 1071 and 30 opposed.
In favor were several lake and watershed associations, the Lake Management Advisory Commission, the Rivers Management Advisory Commission, and the Lake Sunapee Rowing Club.
The vote online at last count was the other direction, perhaps about 1,000 to 600.
So shall we say there is no lack of response to this particular bill.
250 feet clearance, an interest of 100 feet from the present requirement of 150 feet, was chosen as a reasonable step forward in responding to citizen concerns about the detrimental effects of wake surfing waves, height, and strength.
These concerns include damage to shoreline and to docks, as well as boats tied up at docks, and even lounge furniture on the docks.
Further concerns were threats to kayakers, paddleboarders, swimmers, and waiting children confronted with large forceful waves.
Emails cited specific evidence of these threats.
250 feet was also seen as allowing wake surfing activity on virtually all of New Hampshire's water bodies, although it might be limited on some of the narrower portions.
Because Marine Patrol officers are highly trained in determining distances, and some carry laser devices for even more accurate measurement, enforcement would not be made more difficult with a 250-foot separation.
When HB 1071 was filed, the University of Minnesota study was still in peer review.
Recently, the study has been issued, and many of the comments in favor of 1071 are related to the scientific conclusions about wakeboat waves' height and force.
They express a strong desire for a much greater distance than 250 feet.
However, many understand that this bill, as written, is an important step forward.
At the present time, I remain in favor of the distance in this bill as a first step in a fair direction intended to enhance protection of our economically important shoreline and water bodies while allowing wake surfing to continue with minimal adjustment.
As the University of Minnesota study is further examined, it will lead to more research and perhaps legislation to answer some of those questions it has raised.
But that's for tomorrow and not for today.
Thank you.
Any questions of the representative.
Seeing none, you may take your position back on the board, please.
Anybody wants to borrow my copy of the 102-page report, I'll end it.
Chair calls Representative Smith.
Good afternoon, committee members and Mr.
Chair, and thank you for the opportunity to testify.
I am Suzanne Smith.
I represent the towns of Plymouth, Hebron, and Holderness, Grafton County, District 8, home of both Squam Lake and Newfoundland.
am Suzanne Smith.
I represent the towns of Plymouth, Hebron, and Holderness, Grafton County, District 8, home of both Squam Lake and Newfound Lake.
And I'm speaking in support of House Bill 1071, which will extend the safe passage area on our lakes and ponds from 150 feet to 250 feet, only when the boater is engaged in the sport of wake surfing.
If you're just cruising around in your wake boat or any other boat, you would not be subject to the increased distance, nor would you be affected if you are towing a wakeboarder or a water skier.
This bill only applies to the activity of wake surfing.
In 2019-2020, I served as chair of the Commission to Study Wake Boats in New Hampshire.
In addition to state reps and senators, members on the commission represented lake associations in New Hampshire, members of the public, Department of Environmental Services, Marine Patrol, the Marine Trades Organization, water sports industry, and others.
In fact, one gentleman flew up monthly from Florida to attend our meetings.
We didn't always agree, but we did learn a lot about wake boats, wakeboarding, wake surfing, and the wakes that these boats produce, the waves they produce.
We did review a study titled Wake Sport Wave Energy Study, which was funded by the Water Sports Industry Association.
A long-awaited study, which was referenced by Representative Gottling, conducted by St.
Anthony Falls Library at the University of Minnesota, titled Boat-Generated Wake Wave Study, was finally published a week ago.
Now, back when I was on the commission, this study was just being started.
They were just trying to get funding together to do the study.
And it took them, since fall of 2020, when they went out on the lake and did their review of wakes and waves.
It took them this long to release the results because after reviewing the data and doing all their research, it's peer-reviewed.
So it has a lot of people did look at this.
I distributed the FAQs on the study to all of you, so you can take a look at that in your spare time.
And studies put together to learn about the waves produced by different sports is really important, and it's important that that is really trustworthy research because as we know from our field trip last summer or from our personal experiences on our lakes of New Hampshire large waves are necessary to surf the wake the final analysis of the University of Minnesota study was that wake surfing boats fully ballasted, that means they are containing up to 2,000 pounds of water to weigh them down, and being driven at speeds of 10 to 12 miles an hour, which is the speed that works best when a wake surfer is behind the boat, it took 500 feet or the the waves produced, to dissipate at shore.
You know, if it was 250, 200, the waves were still really strong when they got to the shore.
And I do have some maps, which I believe were passed around also, that shows a 500-foot buffer versus the existing 150-foot buffer on some of our major lakes.
Now, Winnipesaukee isn't included because it is so large that there is a lot of space for wake boating and wake surfing on Winnipesaukee.
But Newfound Lake, you can see most of Newfound Lake is still available for wake surfing, because it is a fairly wide lake.
Squam, there are a lot of little coves, so those little coves would be more problematic if you were wake surfing.
However, you can start at your dock no matter where it is on a lake and just travel at headway speed out to that 500-foot area and then do your wake surfing.
If you're not carrying a wake surfer, you only have that 150-foot buffer if this bill passes.
So I ask you to consider.
New Hampshire's waters are held in trust for the public, for the people of New Hampshire.
And yes, those who enjoy motorized water boats, which produce wakes, should be able to.
But the peaceful enjoyment of those who enjoy swimming, sunbathing on their docks, or enjoying non-motorized water activities should not be ignored.
The water belongs to all.
We need to find a balance, and extending the buffer for boats engaged in wakesurfing, which has been shown more than once to produce large waves, larger than water skiing or even tubing, is reasonable.
So I ask for your support for House Bill 1071.
So there's a place for everyone on New Hampshire's lakes, great ponds, and rivers.
And thank you.
And if anyone has any questions, I will try to answer them.
Representative Gould for a question.
Thank you for taking my question.
And does the depth of the lake make a difference with these boats?
Because I always thought that Squam Lake, for example, is rather shallow.
Depth definitely makes a difference.
The engines for these type of boats kind of point the way back, point the energy down.
So the more shallow the lake, the more problematic that can be.
The people at St.
Anthony's Falls, University of Minnesota, their next study is going to be the effects on the underlying ground because there are concerns of sediment being.
We did have on the Wake Boat Study Commission website, there are studies that talk about sediment, and the final report has about two pages on the sediment that's churned up when people are running these boats at speeds where the water is shallow.
Any other questions?
Representative Creighton.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Representative, I appreciate the maps you sent around with the 500 indicated on them.
Those are the biggest lakes in New Hampshire.
As you did your study, how many of the smaller lakes are there wakeboards on?
The concern is that much of that water is taken away, especially in the coves, and so you have a small, narrow strip in the middle of the lake where you can actually use a wakeboat.
On a smaller lake, you're really prohibiting, then boats.
If you get to anything, Franklin Pierce, for example, you probably couldn't use a wake boat because that strip would be so narrow.
What did your study say to that?
What did the commission say to that?
Actually, if I go back to the initial public hearing on the bill that formed the Wake Boat Study Commission, we had people who came and were on small lakes, and there were wake boats on those lakes.
And then we had people who lived on the lakes that had a wake boat, and they said, I just bought this boat.
Now you're going to tell me I can't be on this lake?
And so it's trying to find that balance.
But this bill is particularly for wake surfing.
On wake boats, you can also be doing wakeboarding, which this bill does not apply to, which is where you're – the distance behind the boat that, say, for instance, a water skier would be.
And that is not covered by this legislation.
It's just the wake surfing because there was a study out of Georgia, which I don't have the particulars on, but probably someone behind me could answer that, that talked about the waves produced by wake surfing were so much higher than even for wakeboarding.
So it would limit your use but not eliminate the ability to use the boat and I have asked people who sell the boats do you ask people what lake they're going to use the boat on so they don't get into situation where all of a sudden their neighbors are all complaining because it's such a small lake I mean the the maps I passed around there is one there.
There are a couple small ones on there to show you, and those are lakes that I believe do have at least one wake bone.
Sure.
Any other questions from Representative Cohen?
Thank you for taking my question, Representative Smith.
We've received a lot of emails and a lot of information or pictures of environmental damage from wakes, and I appreciate looking at that as well.
I'm just wondering on your committee, one thing that didn't come across in anything yet was, has anything on your committee discovered anything to exotic species, any damage because of wakeboat surfing?
Do you have any information on that?
On the Wakeboat Study Commission, we did address that.
We had a presentation from Amy Smagula, who's the expert in New Hampshire, in my opinion, on it.
And she did express concerns, but more of her concerns were when on the boats themselves with the ballast bags, filling them with water and taking in eggs and small pieces of plant that are then shot back out into the water of another lake or a different part of that particular lake.
However, when you're talking about shallow water stirring up the bottom, it can definitely unhinge exotic species who then are transmittable to different parts of the lake.
Thank you.
Any other questions from members of the committee?
Seeing none, thank you very much.
You may take your seat back.
Clean off the microphone.
Thank you.
Chair calls John Walley from the New Hampshire Marine Trades Association.
Oh, where are you?
Not here.
Thank you.
Where did he go?
Hey.
All right.
Sorry about that.
My name is John Wally.
I'm the general manager at Silver Sands Marina and the vice president of the New Hampshire Marine Trades Association, and we are here to oppose House Bill 1071.
I'd like to give you an overview of the boating culture in New Hampshire.
The culture is strong.
Boating and fishing providing $1.2 billion to the outdoor recreation portion of the New Hampshire economy in 2020, supporting 275 businesses and 6,800 jobs.
That data comes from 2019, and we anticipate those numbers to be high when reported.
2021, we saw the all-time high of 107,000 boat registrations in the state of New Hampshire, providing people with a lot of fun this summer.
But those boats chose challenges for public use and a lot of active waterways.
It is important to recognize that New Hampshire relies on summer tourism, and recreational boating is a pivotal part of that.
Bills like House Bill 1071 will limit public access.
It will create dangerous water conditions by forcing wake surfers into bigger parts of the lake where boats travel quickly and more densely.
This bill just moves issues into somebody else's backyard.
This poses unintended consequences.
Rather than restricting, we would like to see education.
The New Hampshire Marine Transit Center Station has worked hard in the last year to raise awareness for responsible boating through the Wake Responsibility Campaign.
In 2021, the State Marine Patrol received just 29 calls wake surfing related.
That is of 2,290 statewide service calls.
That's 1%.
Roughly 1%.
Our goal through education is to minimize repetitive passes, continue to keep music levels at a responsible level, stay at least 200 feet from shore, and direct surf waves away from the shore.
Does everyone understand what that means?
Wake surf boats surf on one side of the boat, not both.
So you can drive your boat down the lake and you can focus the wave away from shore, still being within 150 feet of safe passage, or 200, which is the recommended length from the Water Sports Association, or further out.
You do not need to direct your wave toward shore.
While some people may ask if wake surfing is only done on one specific type of boat, that is incorrect.
Wake surfing is gaining popularity year over year because of its slow speed, low impact fun.
It creates a social atmosphere that multi-generations of water sports enthusiasts may enjoy.
It's one of the safest, if not the safest, water sport towed behind boats we have on our lakes today.
And more and more boat manufacturers continue to adapt their models to meet the public demand.
You have been provided now handouts of different types of wake surf boats now offered in the public.
There are new style pontoon boats, personal watercraft, jet boats, deck boats, traditional inboard, traditional inboard outboard bow riders, and even a fishing type of boat that has an employed propulsion.
We are aware that some boaters, mostly due to inexperience, do not understand the current laws of safe passage.
All of the marinas in New Hampshire have pledged to do thorough boat orientations, providing safe training and courteous tow sport operation.
And by that, I mean when we sell a boat, it's expensive.
It's fancy.
It's new.
It's fresh.
It's confusing.
There's a lot going on with it.
And these people typically have done one or two demos or demo orientations with us.
But now they take it home and need to operate it safely with courtesy to their neighbors.
I personally will spend, and I know a lot of my constituents behind me that work at the marina, spend two to three hours on these boats showing them how to operate it properly, safely for friends and loved ones in the water.
I have an eight-year-old daughter.
I want to make sure that she's safe and she's understanding as we're using the boat that she's going to be okay and she understands where to be, where not to be in the boat, in the water.
It's critical.
So that's a very important part of the process.
And we want to make sure that when these people leave with their boat, that they're being good stewards to the lakes that they're on and their neighbors, because we don't need to continue to create bad habits.
House Bill 1071 will create confusion.
Where can people wakeboard?
Where can they water ski but not wake surf?
It could also create a public access concern for those on smaller lakes who will no longer be able to use their boat on their property where they pay taxes.
It's important to point out that laws regarding wake damage are already on our books in New Hampshire, and this is the law.
To provide full visibility and control and to prevent their weight from being thrown into or causing excessive rocking to other boats, barges, water skiers, aquaplanes, rafts, or floats.
All vessels shall maintain headway speed within 150 feet of rafts, floats, swimmers, permitted swimming areas, shores, dock mooring fields, and other vessels.
We have always appreciated the State Marine Patrol has taken an approach of being welcome ambassadors onto our waterways, doing a great job demonstrating the 150-foot passage law without posing tickets.
But it does not mean that we need new current laws and new legislation because borders under don't understand the rules we already have laws on the books do not need further setbacks we need more education my father Mike Wally served in this committee for many years he excuse me sponsored the border education bill and it has been proven through the Coast Guard that states with boater education have fewer fatalities and fewer incidents than those without.
Boater education works.
I ask you, as the Vice President of the New Hampshire Marine's Association, to let us do our jobs, let us be responsible, and continue to demonstrate good habits to new boaters, reaffirm best practices to those already existing in our towboat community while we resolve the challenges through education.
Thank you.
Any questions, Mr.
Walley?
Representative Smith, for a question.
Yeah, I guess you can.
you can.
Well, you can have someone else to go first.
No, no.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
And thank you, Mr.
Walley, for taking my question.
You're welcome.
Nice to see you again.
Yeah, nice to see you again, too.
And I should say that we were cleaning out some file cabinets in the office, and we found a picture of your dad.
Oh, yeah?
His fellow reps on a field trip.
It was pretty nice.
I have a question.
You were testified.
Oh, right.
I can't ask questions.
I forgot.
Yep.
She can ask.
Fire away.
And, you know, I screw up too many times.
Don't let me screw up anymore.
Come on.
Just never mind.
If she wants to pass a note to somebody else, I'm all for it.
Let's go.
If you could find somebody else who wants to ask you a question.
Okay.
Is there anyone else who wishes to ask Mr.
Wally a question?
I just have one question.
You say that when you wake surf, it's unidirectional.
It goes one way or the other way.
Either way.
The boats are designed to allow surfing on either side.
The driver of the boat typically has a software system in the boat that allows you to choose which side of the boat you want to surf.
So it's very easy, very functional to adjust.
The adjustability of it now can happen within three to four seconds.
So there's no real excuse for someone to not be able to surf their surf wave away from shore.
Okay and just an additional question is that true on some of these other craft that are multi-use they can And the ones that are not specifically was it wake boats but other things like pontoon boats and that have the ability to generate I would say that the unique thing about a specific in board is that it's multifunctional first it's a boat that you can take to dinner and get an ice cream cone, water ski with, wake surf, wakeboard.
And the industry saw those shifts and saw that not all consumers wanted that type of style boat by looking that way.
So they're adapting pontoon boats, pre-existing boats, to now work towards surfing because it's such a popular sport.
That's why you see with the handouts fishing boats, a pontoon boat, or people just really have regular old bow riders, and the drive, not to get too technical, is spun around 180 degrees.
So the propeller is no longer towards the back.
It's now pulling the boat forwards, creating safety so that the propeller is not spinning by anyone's foot if they're behind the swim platform off the boat itself.
So they're adapting because the consumers are asking for these products.
If I could point out one more thing, Tim.
During the wake surf study that I was on with Representative Smith, it was brought up that with the concern of aquatic invasive species, only 3 to 4% of typical wake surf boats are transient.
They all kind of live where they go, and they stay on those lakes primarily their whole life while owned.
The lake hosts at a lot of the boat ramps were able to confirm that.
We were all surprised by that, too, but data from the lake hosts at boat ramps were able to confirm that that number was accurate.
It wasn't just basically how we just called around to all of our customers and asked, hey, are you using your boat at your house, at your lake, or are you popping in the trailer and buzzing it around, and then 3% to 4% said, we're moving it around, and 3% to 4%.
And the rest of them said no.
But the lake host said they confirmed that.
And typically when you fill a ballast tank, you don't do it in a water that's shallow.
Most boats are required to idle away from shore.
You need to continue to allow your alternator to help charge your battery.
So you're idling at headway speed, filling your boat away from shore, not near water that has milfoil, not near water with sedimentation, not disturbing the bottom of the lake.
So when I fill a boat on a demo or an orientation, it may take us the better part of a quarter to half a mile until we're out into fresh water where it's full and that we're able to surf.
Just to clear up some of the other questions that were mentioned earlier.
Thank you.
Representative Huff for our question.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman, and thank you for taking my question.
You mentioned earlier, and I might have the number wrong, that there was 107,000 voter registrations last year.
That's correct.
Is there any way to tell how many of those voter registration people wakes up?
I don't, that's a hard question to answer.
There's probably someone in the back of the room that maybe can answer better than I can.
A lot of our boats are purchased for people that want the accessibility to do it.
I'm always surprised sometimes when we go pick up a boat at the customer's house for the winter and we check the hours versus this year or last year, and it may only have 25 hours on it.
Some have more, which we love to see.
But not every boat is used 100% of the time to wake surf.
I myself, on a normal year, will average 100 hours.
I would estimate that I probably use it that way 25 hours.
We're doing a lot of ice cream runs, a lot of sunset cruises, go to breakfast.
It's just kind of like having an SUV.
Just because you have an SUV or a pickup truck, you don't go to a Home Depot or go to the ski area every minute of the day.
You jump the kids off at school and go to the grocery store and do a lot of different things.
So it's a very utilitarian boat that allows for a lot of different access and a lot of different sports and a lot of different purposes.
Thank you.
Representative Cohen for a question.
Mr.
Wall, I thank you for taking my question.
So the current statute says that wake surfing needs to be done behind a boat that's specifically designed for wake surfing.
With some of these newer boats like the pontoon boats, do they have that same kind of propulsion system that the wake boat now has?
Yes, they've been amended or modified to be safe.
The last thing any of these manufacturers want to do is have some inclusive foot.
And in that statute that we did during our wake study, that was our concern, is that there were people that wanted to wake surf.
And they were buying any kind of a boat, filling it with tubs of concrete, cinder blocks, bags of water, so that it would kind of pump up the wave to make it surf in some capacity.
And we've all deemed that it was exceptionally dangerous.
And also in that study, too, we added that wave surfing should be surfed with life jackets, like in the ocean.
It was a positive event that we did during the study that we came away with a lot of good things that improved the sport and improved people's safety.
Thank you.
Representative Bost for a question.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair, and thank you for being here today.
Last year we had something come up like this, and we talked about wakeboats, and it was my understanding that out of any vessel you're on the water with, you could make it a wakeboat.
But it seems now that there is a boat specifically made that is a wakeboat.
That's my question.
Our primary manufacturers, Malibu, Mastercraft, Dautique, and various others, have specific technology built into their boats, and it basically has a trim tab, and a trim tab is designed to help kind of settle the boat to do what you want it to do, whether it ride more comfortably, surf, do various things.
Those boats are purposely built.
More manufacturers now are kind of getting into ways to modify their boats to do that also.
Does that answer your question?
Yes, thank you.
In a safe fashion.
It's through the manufacturer.
It's not done at home.
So it's done on a level that meets lawyers and insurance and everything else, too.
Anyone else?
Same.
Thank you, Mr.
Waller, for being here.
Chairman, for letting me ask.
My question is, when you're teaching somebody, when you're going through that guided tutorial of the boat, do you have a rule or do you have some way of teaching them what 150 feet looks like?
Because I don't think I could say what 150 feet is.
Yeah, we do.
We're fortunate enough that we have at our marina a gas dock that comes off of our property.
And there's a big flamingo-looking pink building.
And when we get past that, I kind of put the boat to idle and designate to them, this is 150 feet.
My bigger concern with this new law Thank you.
to idle and designate to them, this is 150 feet.
My bigger concern with this new law or bill that's on the books is I don't know how, people have a tough time at 150 feet.
You can just say it yourself.
And I'm sure if we all stood in a line and closed our eyes and walked 150 feet to what we all thought was 150 feet, we'd all be in different spots, especially to where shorelines are not static.
They move.
They are curved and stopped.
I see it as a big concern that if 150 feet is hard to gauge, that's half a football field, half a soccer field roughly.
250 feet is kind of a strange number.
It doesn't really correlate to a football field.
It's not 300 feet long.
And it's even more concerning where all this topic now, 500 feet, that's a long way.
I have a pretty good eye, I feel, and I have a pretty good gauge of distance.
I could not tell you what 500 feet is.
And I actually looked it up this morning trying to find what is 500 feet?
A 10-story building is 100 feet tall.
So we don't have 10-story buildings in Concord, not to my knowledge.
But that's five of them stacked up.
That's a long way.
And that's a hard way to gauge for anybody in the public.
And I think it's important to remember, too, that 250 really means 500.
It's just on both sides of the shoreline.
It's not 250 on one side of the shoreline.
So if it's a narrow lake, then that compounds even more.
If it's 500 feet on either side of the shoreline, your window of opportunity is small.
You're going to have a lot of boats running that same pattern, people in the water.
It poses some serious concerns.
Thank you.
Representative Post, for a second time.
Do you believe that would preclude a lot of the lakes in New Hampshire not being able to have wake boats there because of the 500-foot restriction?
Based off my opinion, yes.
Based off the amount of fact and investment you need to look into that, I can't answer that question honestly.
I know that a lake is not a circle.
There's coves, there's pockets, some are long, some are wide.
It would definitely cause a lot of lakes, I think, to be having limited areas where they can and can't use.
I was disappointed.
I read a testimony that was added on to the opposition in four.
And a lot of people – I shouldn't say a lot, but a handful of people said, I live in this cove.
It's this many feet wide.
If this passes, they can ban these boats.
And that's the verbiage that someone said in the email, which I was kind of disappointed by and surprised because I feel as though anyone, including my mother, who owns as a home of Winnipesaukee or any other lake, you're there for the time being.
This is not something that you're there forever.
These lakes are in public access.
You're lucky enough to have property on the shoreline while you're here on this earth, and it's going to be someone else's later on.
And that's important that we don't limit who can be on a lake, where and when.
I had someone else who was a Wake Surf customer.
She said, you know, it'd be great if they could eliminate and say, there's only so many boats on a lake at any particular day.
I said, they would never be able to be able to enforce that, number one.
And number two, what gives you the right to be on the lake more than somebody else because you're a taxpayer that owns the property?
That's just not New Hampshire.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Is there anyone else for a question?
Seeing none, thank you very much.
Thank you.
Chair calls David Neals from New Hampshire DES.
Pardon?
Thank you.
good afternoon mr chair members of committee thanks for having me here today.
My name is David Neils.
I work for the Department of Environmental Services.
I'm the chief water pollution biologist.
And DES takes no position on this bill, but we would like to offer some facts and comments on various things about it.
in 2021 House Bill 115 defined wake surfing as an activity and we think that was a really important step in moving this consideration of this activity forward that is is really important because we think that defining it as as an activity is really helpful for safety patrols can observe the activity going on versus trying to define the boat that's on the water body.
Vessels are also specifically designed, as Mr.
Wally just talked about, to participate in the activity or not participate in the activity, depending on the controls and the way the boat is set up and we also think that by addressing the activity these vessel restrictions can be avoided so rather than banning of certain boat type from a water body by it's just being a certain type of boat the activity can be controlled.
I also want to point out that DES was part of the 2019 Wake Boat Commission that explored the recreational benefits of this activity as well as the safety concerns and the environmental risk.
I want to talk about some of the risks that were pointed out on that Wake Boat Commission and those were primarily things that were mentioned before shoreline erosion and aquatic invasive species this bill House Bill 1071 really addresses the environmental environmental concern of shoreline erosion and the fact that the wakeboat commission and the report that was put out acknowledged the fact that these boats produce larger, more powerful waves.
And I want to talk about the study that was brought up earlier, specifically the one from University of Minnesota that was just released.
And this study and a couple of facts I want to point out, the maximum wave size produced by wake surfing boats at the 150 foot mark from water from the shoreline are basically twice the size of a regular inboard outboard motor which is sort of what most people see on lakes.
So that's you know basically from that distance wake boats were shown to have about a 15 inchinch maximum wave height versus an inboard-outboard vessel, which was 6 inches.
Similarly, that same study measured energy, and that the energy of waves were 5 times higher from wake boats, and that the power of the waves were 10 times higher from wake boats than from a regular inboard-outboard vessel.
And again, DES does not take a position on this.
I just wanted to make sure that those facts were clearly stated.
Research also shows that by increasing, and I think this is really important, increasing the distance from 150 feet to a 250 feet 250 foot setback as proposed as is proposed by this legislation that the wake or the weight and the maximum wave size from a wake boat would decrease by 27 percent and that the power would power of the wave would decrease by 48% and the energy of the wave would decrease by 35%.
So there is some advantage in increasing that weight or that setback if you're looking to decrease the size, the power, and the energy of a wave reaching the shoreline.
Wave size, power, and energy are the most problematic on protected shorelines.
And I think that's really important to point out.
It's not every shoreline that is subjected to these waves.
Protected shorelines are ones that are protected from wind.
So this proposed bill may eliminate some of the wake surf waves in these areas, but certainly not all.
There are certain wave or shorelines that are still protected from wind that could still certainly be subjected to larger waves.
So DES understands the recreational value of wake surfing and certainly understand the value of our lakes.
We look forward to working with the industry and recreational water users to minimize the environmental risks that wake boats were recognized to present in the 2020 Wake Boat Commission report.
We think that this bill takes a step forward to addressing one of these risks, namely shoreline erosion, while simultaneously, and I think this again is really important to recognize, by doing this through attempting to regulate the activity that rather than the vessel type I think that's really a critical step forward in this legislation and thank you for the opportunity and I'm happy to answer any questions that you might have any questions representative post thank you.
Chair, and thank you for your testimony today.
My question is, now with these boats having the ability to direct the wave opposite from the shore, do you feel there's still a concern about the wave action against the shore since they will have the ability at a push of a button to change it if they're going around in circles or whatever?
So I'm not a wakeboat owner, so I don't know everything about the wakeboats.
I know that that is certainly an advantage.
I think that presents a certain amount of subjective sort of decision to be made by the safety patrols that are out there.
It would be hard to tell, I think, from the distance that they would travel, unless they were very close to define which way the surf wave was being directed.
And I'm not sure how new that technology is.
I know it's been around for a while.
I'm not sure that all the boats that are out there that would be doing this activity have the capability of directing the particular side of the wave, the surf wave.
Thank you very much.
You're welcome.
Any other questions?
Representative Egan.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you, sir, for taking my question.
In your testimony, you referenced the Minnesota report and its estimated footage.
Can you give us a perception of what other five New England states are doing, knowing that changing any sort of rule for participation on a waterfront can change how tourists look at the state?
and given that's our second largest to general tourism is our second largest generator of economy it's important to sort of factor in what our competition in New England for tourists does so if you could give us a little insight into our neighbors thank you for the question I think that's an excellent question if you're asking me if I know whether other states in New England have similar setback restrictions, I can't honestly answer that question well for you.
There may be somebody in the building here in the room here today that knows more about the safety regulations from other states.
follow up does your office your agency working to communicate with some of those other agents states.
Follow-up?
Does your office, your agency, work to communicate with some of those other agencies that that information can get sourced?
Certainly we could pick that up for you.
Yeah, absolutely.
Wonderful.
Thank you, sir.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Representative Mayfield.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
And thank you, Mr.
Neils, for taking the question.
And this is related to the Minnesota study.
So I just had a couple of questions that, as a scientist, that hopefully you'll be able to answer for me.
I can't find the study in the academic library, so I'm trying to kind of hunt that down.
But looking at the sample size, that's the N in academia, it's very small with four boats.
And I'm wondering about the confounding variable because I don't see those anywhere.
And things such as the depth of water that was tested, the water temperature, the roughness of the surface at the time of the testing, that to me would conclude that perhaps this study might not be generalizable to the state of New Hampshire lakes.
So I'm wondering what your opinion might be on that.
And thank you for the answer.
Yes, absolutely.
So I will say, as some of the others have mentioned, the study, which is available, I'm happy to share it with you, it did go through a very thorough review process.
They do give some basic morphometric measures of the water body, as well as what the depth was that they ran the boats in.
And I will say that, you know, as part of a scientific study, Thank you.
morphometric measures of the water body, as well as what the depth was that they ran the boats in.
And I will say that, you know, as part of a scientific study, one of the things you want to do is replicate the same conditions for each of the boats that you're running, each of the experiments that you're running.
And they did run the experiment with all four boats in the same exact area.
And that they also ran each of those boats multiple times and got the same measures through each of those sort of they're called replicates so yeah that that was done I found the study to to be very objective and very informative and well done so it's it's a very well thought out and useful study I think as people start thinking about how this how this issue could be addressed I don't think you quite answered my question sure what I'm asking is is the lake that this study was done on generalizable to New Hampshire lakes was at the same depth as all of the lakes that we see in New Hampshire you see what I mean so you do it on one lake but is that the same kind of a lake the same depth the same surface the same water area the same surrounding edges as a New Hampshire lake I get that it's peer-reviewed and that's definitely a tight study but does it match our lakes here well so that's a really tough question the answer because our lakes here vary in size depth roughness and all those various components I feel like the lake that they did their work on they provide some information about it and I think it is transferable to the conditions we have here in New Hampshire it's it tends to be in a similar cold climactic area that's been glaciated, so the sediment type and shoreline type is likely to be relatively similar.
I'd have to go back and look at the exact details of what the depths and everything that we're run through.
Yeah, you're welcome.
Is there any other questions?
Seeing none.
Thank you.
Oh, I'm sorry.
No, no.
Go ahead.
Just a simple question.
Thank you for being here, Mr.
Nils.
Could you just define the difference between energy and power, just for if you don't mind?
Well, I'm not a physicist.
I am a biologist.
So energy is the ability of the wave to do work, and power is the amount of work that it does over an amount of time.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Anyone else?
Seeing no one?
Thank you very much.
Chair calls Jody Grimlis and Mike Farrelly for five minutes.
Representing New Hampshire Marine Trades Association and Water Sports Industry Association.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman, members of the committee.
My name is Jody Grimbelis.
I'm a lobbyist here in Concord.
I'm always in your committee.
I know I actually see most of you.
I represent the New Hampshire Marine Trades Association.
I also do work for the Water Sports Industry Association, the National Marine Manufacturers Association.
I'm going to have Mike here, Forelli, is going to speak to a letter that you would have received in your emails from Peter McCallum, who could not attend.
You've seen him before, your committee.
Mike is going to cover the high points of his testimony, and then I will offer a couple things and hopefully answer a couple questions that came up so I will turn it to Mike good afternoon mr.
chairman and members of the committee my name is Michael Farrelly I have worked McCallum's Boathouse for some 15 years alongside Peter McCallum the current president of the New Hampshire Marine Trades Association who is out of state and cannot be present today my personal background is that I've been a bo my whole life.
I have served on the board of directors of the New Hampshire Lakes Association in 2017 and 2018, worked and volunteered for the New Hampshire Lakes with their Lake Coast program for many years, and have boated all over New Hampshire as well as many other states in the country.
My personal love of the water and boating is why I have chosen this career path.
I am proud of the work of the marine industry in New Hampshire.
The main, there will be plenty of testimony about House Bill 1071 and how it should not pass.
The main focus of my testimony today is one of the reasons why.
It is called the New Hampshire Wake Responsibly Campaign.
It's a public and private partnership between industry and New Hampshire Marine Patrol to specifically educate water sports enthusiasts about best practices for wake surfing.
New Hampshire Marine Trades Association committed to this committee during last year's debate on House Bill 229 that we would undertake such an effort and i would like to report our results in the summer 2021 a local and national boating industry contributed over fifteen thousand dollars in funds and additional personnel and resource time toward building a campaign to educate families about the best best practices and proper etiquette for wake.
It is based on the national campaign called Wake Responsibly that promotes three practices.
One, staying 200 feet from shore when wake surfing.
Two, playing music at a reasonable level.
And three, minimizing repetitive passes.
In partnership with New Hampshire Marine Patrol and New Hampshire Association of broadcasters we created two radio advertisements that ran from June through August as well as three social media ads that were distributed through marina social media platforms and boater voting databases to get the message out these safety messages were heard by New Hampshire residents and vacationers alike the ad ran 2,363 times for total total dollar or messages were heard by New Hampshire residents and vacationers alike the ad ran 2,363 times for total total dollar value of fifty eight thousand four hundred ninety six dollars according to the New Hampshire Association of broadcasters in addition New Hampshire Marine Patrol marina members and individual boaters installed signage at public and private boat launches across the state additionally palm cards marketing stands and stickers compliance exams have been used by local marinas to assist an educational campaign with water sports families finally the New Hampshire Department of Safety included the New Hampshire wake responsibly campaign messaging and its recent boat registration renewal notices that was mailed to a hundred and seven thousand voters we strongly believe that this message is catching on we believe efforts to change course now when the campaign is connecting with voters is ill-advised I will take it for a couple more seconds couple more topics on behalf of the water sports industry Association National Marine Manufacturers Association and the marine retailers associations of America I have a letter in opposition to the bill this is probably the first bill of this this nature to establish such a far setback and then have the discussion of the 500-foot Minnesota study.
It might be the first time it's being heard today.
It's very concerning to the overall industry.
I'm not going to read the letter.
I'm going to pass it out, but I think you'll get some of the same points and some of the testimony today.
A couple other things.
There were a lot of folks that could not make today because of work or family challenges with child care, but they sent me a lot of letters that I printed out, which I will put for the file, but a couple asked me to point out particular issues.
The Lakes Region Tourism Association, which boasts 450 businesses in Central and the Lakes Region of New Hampshire.
As opposed to this bill, they're concerned about the tourist economy, our residents and tourists, and what kind of message are we sending for recreational boaters that really take up a lot of our bringing a lot of revenue to our community.
There's a second letter which I think is of interest.
It's a member of, it's a boater from the seacoast who boats on Great Bay and questioned the language of the bill that said this bill applies to inland waters.
Does that include Great Bay or some of those rivers, Bellamy River, et cetera?
It's a very good question.
I called Captain Dunlavy.
We weren't sure what the answer was.
So I raised that question for you, that we're not sure how far does this go.
The other thing that that homeowner wanted me to know is that in living in Great Bay, they are part of a living shoreline project.
It kind of makes me think of Representative Post's legislation about having shorefront owners have abilities to kind of buttress up their shorelines.
They are part of that project at UNH, DES, and a lot of coastal program groups are part of that.
But what he has on his testimony is that part of that site evaluation, boat weight pressure is unlikely to be causing the erosion, is a statement in the document.
and he wanted to make sure that we knew, or that I passed along, that the issue of erosion is not generally wake-related.
And then the last voter specifically asked me to mention his letter.
He is a double master's degree geophysicist engineer with transportation and engineering background.
But he has given me an entire letter of review of that University of Minnesota study.
Some of the questions that Representative Mayville asked are kind of noted in here.
There are questions about the type of boats used.
One of the boats used was a very well-designed, light, tournament ski boat, which most folks would know is going to make the least wake, the smallest wake possible.
So I think there's questions about that.
There's also more scientific things that I don't always understand.
So I will pass this packet in as well.
Finally, Representative Egan, you had a question about setbacks in other states.
I had asked National to give me a little bit of understanding.
Not everybody has a 150-foot setback like New Hampshire does.
Connecticut has a 100-foot setback.
They have 200 feet for different personal watercraft.
Delaware has 100 feet.
Georgia has 100 feet.
Indiana has 200 feet.
Maine has 200 feet while towing.
Michigan has 100 feet.
Massachusetts doesn't have one, but they do have a statewide law saying you cannot be within 100 feet of a swimming area.
So just to give you some sense, Virginia has a 50-foot setback.
Florida doesn't have a setback.
You have a 300-foot setback if you're near a commercial vessel or the law enforcement.
What we're looking at here is, again, much further than that.
It would be unprecedented, and I would want to make sure that New Hampshire would realize that we would be the first to undertake such a setback.
And that has unintended consequences that I think you'll hear from others behind me.
The last piece I'll make, and then I'll be quiet, we talk about safety and enforcement.
The Department of Safety has given us some great statistics.
I appreciate the help from Captain Dunleavy.
We've talked about the increase in boat registrations, and just to give you a snapshot, 2017 we had about 95,000 boats registered.
And I will leave these with the committee too.
2021, 106,000, 107,000 boats.
Accidents in 2017, 50.
Accidents in 2021, 39.
Calls for service in 2017, 2,304.
Calls for service in 2021, 2,290, about 14 shy.
They do give summons, or I call tickets, for safe passage.
2017, 171 tickets, but 683 warnings.
As Marine Patrol has always done, they really try to educate folks first, which I think is very good in terms of our tourism.
In 2020, the last numbers they have, 166 tickets, 659 warnings.
So there are efforts to educate from Marine Patrol and enforce the laws that we have.
But I think the most important statistic that they have in this document is the number of officers.
The number of officers for Marine Patrol was 35 in 2017.
The number of officers in 2021 is 35.
There was a peak in 2019 of 44.
This committee is recommending an interim study on a bill to look at vessel registrations.
We've talked to Captain Dunley about the need to look at those.
We need to look at our law enforcement.
We need to look at Marine Patrol.
That is a better answer to the issues on the lakes than what this bill is here before you.
So again, I thank you, and we'll take any questions.
I'd be happy to take any questions about wake boats or surfing specifically as well.
Does anyone have any questions of those testifying?
Representative Cohen?
Thank you for taking me.
I'm sorry, I didn't write down your last name, sir.
Fairly.
Mr.
Fairly, just a curiosity.
So the New Hampshire Wake Responsibility Program, you say, is being very successful.
Can you just help me understand what your criteria is for successful?
I don't know if it is or not because there are a lot of people wanting this bill to become law as well.
So can you just tell me how do you define and know what success is?
I'm not challenging if it's successful, but what are you using or what makes you say, okay, I can say it's successful?
Sure.
And I think a lot of that comes to word of mouth, whether it's successful, but what are you using or what makes you say, okay, I can say it's successful?
And I think a lot of that comes to word of mouth, whether it be talking to somebody in person or on posts on social media, what you see out there.
But these three main focuses is what we've been pushing towards people.
I, like John Wally, spend hours with somebody in their new boat to orient them about the boat and then about boating safety as well as courtesy.
And five years ago, this conversation wasn't happening, and not many people knew about it, but a lot of the people that I'll bring this up to nowadays already know what I'm talking about and what I'm about to say.
And that goes for staying 200 feet away, keeping the music low, and then minimizing the repetitive passes.
That's a big one so that you're not in front of the same group of individuals, houses, businesses all day long.
But it would be tough to completely gauge how many people this has been introduced to.
But all I can say is from my personal experience and experiences of people like me, like John Wally, we see a lot more individuals that are educated on this than we have in years past.
Thank you for your answer.
I would just add one other thing.
One of the great programs I think many people agree to is the Lake Host Program.
The Lake Host Program was a volunteer clean, drain, and dry your boat before you go into your next launch.
20 years, that was a volunteer.
There was no law.
It was just education, education, education.
That seems to have been a very, and continues to be a very successful program.
That was actually added into law, I think, two years ago in 2019, but it hadn't been.
It had been worked on.
I also, and again, this is very anecdotal, but the written complaints to Marine Patrol two years ago were 30 about wake boats, and this year there were nine.
So I'm going to say that maybe we're making some progress.
Any other questions?
Seeing none.
Thank you.
If you could, anything you have to pass in.
Okay, and if you have any copies of your testimony, that would be appreciated as well.
Okay.
All right.
June Fichter, representing SELF and LSPA.
I presume L stands for lake.
Yes, yes, it does.
I have copies of mine.
Okay.
Put your copies there, and then he'll make his second pass.
Thank you.
Yes, yes, yes.
I have copies of mine.
Okay, put your copies there, and then he'll make his second pass.
I also have one full copy of the study.
I only have one of those, but okay.
Okay, let him finish passing stuff out.
It's hard to speak through a mask, so excuse me.
Well, thank you very much for giving me the opportunity to lend my support for House Bill 1071.
I speak for myself and also the Lake Centipede Association, the board, and our members as well.
Earlier, a gentleman did quote what I will quickly do.
The current law in the book is Chapter 270D2 of the New Hampshire Boating and Water Safety to provide visibility control and prevent wakes from being thrown into or causing excessive rocking to water skiers barges boats swimmers docks shore etc that currently applies to all boats including boats.
And that is from the 1990s.
The recently released peer review study, as by now you know, from the University of Minnesota compared wakes of wake surfing boats and wakes from ordinary boats.
We should consider that the current 150 distance intended for non-wake surfing boats should be increased proportionally for boats generating bigger wakes than those in the 1990s.
The question is, how much?
And in the graphs, at 100 feet, the study showed that wakeboat wake heights were two to three times that of non-wakesurfing boats.
And the power, as was previously stated, was up more than that, six times approximately.
So the study indicates that distances of over 400 feet, 425 feet, are needed for wake surf boats wakes to be equivalent, if you will, to non-wake boats at that same distance.
So I urge the committee to, one, either pass House Bill 1071, as is.
It's not enough, but it's an improvement over what we have today, which goes back to the 1990s.
90 two, preferably to consider an amendment increasing the distance to further than 250.
And I understand that's a compromise, a judgment call.
350, which would be my preference, gets us 80% of the way there if you look at those graphs.
In terms of tourism, I have to say what we're talking about here isn't so much erosion.
It is, and I do have members who complain about that, and it depends what kind of shore you have.
But in terms of tourism, you know, kayakers complain that the wakes near shore are too big to kayak.
It's too big to swim, to have kids swimming.
It's too big to, you know, it just interrupts that small 1990s distance interrupts other kinds of activities on the lake.
So the lakes aren't only for people with big expensive boats with big wakes.
So I just wanted to point that out.
So we're in support of House Bill 10-71.
Any questions that I can answer?
Representative Post for a question.
Thank you.
I didn't get your name.
Oh, June Fichter.
C-H is a hard C-H.
F-I-C-H-T-E-R, and I'm the executive director of the Lake Centipede Protective Association, and also I am fortunate enough to live on Lake Centipede, and I do have a ski boat.
I'm not, you know, I sail, I kayak, I also, our family water skis, so we enjoy sometimes just a cocktail cruise and and it'd be nice not to spill my beer, but, you know, it's enough said.
Thank you very much.
You're welcome.
Anyone else?
Seeing none.
Oh, excuse me.
Representative Egan.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you, Matt, for taking my question.
Given that you water ski, are there rules that you're required to abide by for distance to shore for water skiing?
For water skiing, on the books, it's still 150 feet, but we don't do that.
We go in the middle of the lake.
And I should say that we have some wakeboat owners who are members who are for this bill, and they always practice in the middle of the lake, not in narrow spots.
Thank you.
Any other questions?
Seeing none.
Thank you very much.
No?
You notice I'm trying to go pro, con, pro, con.
This is now someone in opposition.
The Raymond family.
Steve, Emily, and Samantha.
You asked for five minutes.
I hope it's not five minutes each.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Mr.
Chairman and members of the committee.
For the record, my name is Steve Raymond.
This is my wife, Emily, and my daughter, Samantha.
I'm a New Hampshire native, born and raised in Goffstown.
When I was eight years old, my parents bought a camp on Lake Winnesquam, where we spent many summers water skiing and tubing on the lake.
It was our family time.
Thank you.
born and raised in Gothstown.
When I was eight years old, my parents bought a camp on Lake Winnesquam where we spent many summers water skiing and tubing on the lake.
It was our family time.
In the 90s, I took to wakeboarding and eventually competed at the national level.
I met my wife, Emily, through friends at the lake, and we spent much of our younger days working towards the goal of what is sometimes termed lake life.
Today, Emily and I live in Manchester, raising our 11-year-old daughter Samantha.
We continue the tradition of family time on the lake in the summer, sometimes wakeboarding, sometimes tubing, and oftentimes wakesurfing.
We love it all.
I'd like to offer our opposition to HB 1071 based on our family's experience with boating and enjoyment of wakesurfing.
I'd also like to offer my knowledge as an engineer on the causes of erosion and how this bill is misguided.
We've been very lucky to spend many summers on Lake Winnesquam.
Recreational boating and water sports are very important to our family.
We are outside with friends, family, enjoying New Hampshire and its natural resources.
We are limiting screen time for the kids and enjoying each other's company.
About three years ago I stopped wakeboarding and turned to full-time wakesurfing as wakesurfing is a great sport that can keep you active and healthy and you can share the experience with a lot of people.
My daughter has wakeboarded and wakesurfed since she was five and absolutely loves her time on the water with her parents, extended family, and friends.
We are also avid paddleboarders on the lake.
We take our boating very Thank you.
and absolutely loves her time on the water with her parents, extended family, and friends.
We are also avid paddleboarders on the lake.
We take our boating very seriously.
It's important to learn the laws and be courteous to others.
I feel like the reason we are here today is because some boaters don't act in the same manner.
I don't believe it is always purposeful.
I think they are just unaware.
We are responsible and respectful when we surf.
We watch our distances, obey the laws, and often surf with the wave directed toward the middle of the lake.
It is out of courtesy and in line with current laws.
These laws work.
We have yet to see any damage to shoreline that can be attributed to the sport.
Which brings me to my professional knowledge.
Because of my love of water when I was young, I wanted to pursue a career in civil and environmental engineering.
I went to WPI, graduated with a degree in civil engineering with a concentration in environmental.
After I graduated, I took a job with one of New England's leading environmental engineering firms as an entry-level engineer.
I have been at the same firm for over 20 years and I have worked almost almost exclusively in the environmental remediation industry, which specializes in the cleanup of environmentally impacted areas.
I am currently a senior vice president of construction management, responsible for the implementation of remediation projects throughout the country, including significant cleanups of water bodies, groundwater, and soil.
I am currently managing one of the largest environmental cleanup projects in the country on the Gowanus Canal in Brooklyn, New York.
Many of our remediation projects include restoration of wetlands and shorelines.
Because of this background, I understand the water-related issues that can affect remediation and restoration projects.
I also understand the water-related issues that impact our shorelines that from what I've read and heard are incorrectly attributed to wakesurfing.
What I hope the committee understands is that there are many factors that contribute to erosion more than wakesurfing ever could.
These factors include development, improper shoreline improvements, stormwater runoff, ice, wind, and water levels.
For example, ice is a factor that many do not think of because they don't see it or understand its impact.
It's out of sight, therefore out of mind.
However, during the winter months and in the spring, ice can cause significant damage and erosion to shorelines.
During the hard winter freeze, ice forms around the rocks and soil in the shoreline, and if lake levels fluctuate either upward or downward, the ice will push rocks further up onto the shore, destabilizing the soil below it, or it can pull rocks into the water, destabilizing the soil above.
In addition, during the spring thaw, ice drifts moving due to quick melting or due to wind can pull rock and soil off the shore or can push rocks and soil up onto the shore.
These natural events described above cause more erosion in one season than years of wave action from a boat could ever cause to the shoreline.
I am happy to tell you more or answer any questions about these factors in erosion of our shorelines.
HB 1071 is misguided.
There is no need to establish a separate setback for wake surfing.
It will cause confusion and will not solve problems related to inexperienced boat or operation on the lakes, nor will it address issues related to erosion that are more impacted by other natural factors.
Thank you for your time and consideration.
Thank you.
Is there any questions by members of the committee?
Representative Creighton.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Sir, thank you for your testimony.
The lake that you boat on with your family, if this law passed, what would that do to the skiable water that you have available to you?
So, I mean, Winnesquam is one of the bigger lakes in New Hampshire.
I think it's either the third or fourth largest.
It is a long, skinny lake, so it would, in effect, take away many portions of the lake and only allow the widest portions of the lake to be available for wake surfing.
And I think one of the concerns with that is, you know, Winnesquam is a lake that has a lot of boaters, you know, especially on the weekends.
It gets very busy.
And if you're now trying to concentrate everybody in one area of the lake, just being able to follow the safe passage rule on 150-foot setback of, you know, whether it's about cruising, about water skiing, about tubing, about wake surfing, you know, especially with the wake surface, they're all going to be in one spot on the lake.
So I think it has a potential to be a serious safety issue, you know, even on the larger lakes.
Okay, thank you.
Representative Egan.
Mr.
Chair, if it may please you, I don't have a question.
I just want to commend you bringing your daughter to testify.
I think it's important that young people get an understanding of how our process works, and I applaud you, sir.
Thank you.
I will say she's upset with me because three years ago she had testimony, and she couldn't testify because of COVID, and this time she didn't have one ready but I wish she had.
Follow-up Mr.
Chair.
May I ask your daughter a question sir?
Sure.
So what do you like about wake surfing?
Honestly, it's just really fun and it's very relaxing too and it's nice to be able to do with friends and family.
Thank you for your testimony.
Thank you.
Representative Post.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman, and thank you, Raymond, for coming.
It's Emily.
Demi, may I ask your daughter a question?
Yes.
Okay, Demi.
So, Demi, you're the future of New Hampshire.
Sammy, sorry.
Say it?
Sammy.
You're the future of New Hampshire, and we all really appreciate you coming here, as a representative stated.
So I just wanted to ask you a question as a young person, and that is, you know, you've learned a lot about boating.
What do you think helps these inexperienced boaters?
In your experience, what helps?
I don't really know that much.
What do you think helps people to know the rules?
Did you learn things about how to safely operate a boat from your parents and from the New Hampshire laws and from postings on signs?
Okay, thank you.
That's what I needed to know.
Thank you very much for taking my question.
Representative Post for a question.
Thank you.
I did not see that you submitted any testimony online.
Would you be able to send that to the committee?
Yes.
Thank you.
Any other questions from members of the committee?
Seeing none, thank you very much.
Thank you very much.
Okay.
A few more.
On the supporting side, Michelle Davis, New Hampshire Lakes.
Oh, yeah.
We've got another couple of hours.
Don't worry, folks.
You don't need to go home for dinner.
One, two.
Thank you.
Thank you, Chair and Zullo, members of the committee.
We're passing around testimony from New Hampshire Lakes, but also letters from the Lakes Management Advisory Committee and the Rivers Management Advisory Committee.
I wanted to thank you.
My name is Michelle Davis.
I'm the Policy and Advocacy Program Manager at New Hampshire Lakes.
And we are in support of House Bill 1071 and encourage the committee to amend the bill to be more protective of lake health.
I will keep this brief.
You've already heard a lot of testimony.
But as you've heard, the University of Minnesota study concluded that at least 500 feet are needed for wake surfing waves to diminish compared to waves created by non-wakesurf boats.
And I just wanted to address a few arguments that you've heard and will continue to hear.
One being that the study was potentially not comprehensive.
The authors acknowledge that there are many other types of boats that were not included in the study.
I would also point out that the study was conducted, excuse me, on an empty lake.
It did not test or address the compounding impact of multiple on-water activities all producing wakes.
Several other studies from around the country have come to the same conclusion that increased setbacks all greater than 250 feet are necessary to mitigate the impact of enhanced waves from wake surfing.
Second, the study did not address impacts on shorelines and lake bottoms this is valid that said it's common knowledge that waves erode shorelines and that the bigger the waves the more energy they have and the more damaging effect they have on shoreline stability a georgia study indicated that at a 250 foot setback waves for wake surfing produces waves with more than six times the energy of those produced by a cruising vessel when they reach the shoreline third uh that requiring an increased setback will concentrate wake surfing activities in the center of our lakes simple mapping exercises show that this is true for some of the smaller lakes but without protective zoning approaches like increased setbacks for high impact activities we are in real danger of loving our lakes to death it won't concentrate necessarily all activities um there'll it'll there'll still be plenty of space on a lot of our lakes left for you know tubers to use one lane potentially and wake surfers to use another and just finally I will say that we are not suggesting that wake surfing should be banned from New Hampshire's lakes we maintain that when done far enough from shore and in deep enough water wake surfing is a fun activity for families and water sports enthusiasts alike with minimal impacts to Lake health I thank you for the opportunity comment.
We urge you to help keep New Hampshire's lakes clean and healthy by amending House Bill 1071.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Is there any questions?
Any questions from the committee?
Seeing none, thank you very much.
Thank you.
Okay.
In opposition, Shane Carey.
Thank you members of the committee.
My name is Shane Carey and I live in Nottingham with my wife and kids.
I work in the auto industry and have enjoyed boating on Patakwe Lake for decades.
I'm here to testify in opposition to House Bill 1071.
I had the pleasure of serving on House Bill 137, Legislative Commission on wake boats.
We spent almost a year studying all aspects of the issue.
The proposal for this setback in House Bill 1071 was never discussed.
At one meeting, we did hear from a wave energy expert who explained his study on waves.
He was upfront that his study was sponsored by water sports industry, but it was clear findings were his own.
He had a 30-year career at MIT as an engineer and now is a consultant.
His report showed that the best practices for wake surfing would be 200 feet from shore.
He also noted that the waves from the surfing were similar to those created by a 10 mile an hour wind.
The pushback on the study from a New Hampshire Lakes representative on the commission was that his study was not peer reviewed.
I've been told that Mr.
Gaudi's study is currently going through the peer review process we should not pass House Bill 1071 we should wait to see the results of that review in my experience the best way to change behavior is through education and communication we've discussed wake responsibility campaign during the Commission and we have worked hard to develop and implement campaign to educate boaters I can I can tell you a story about a boater on Patakaway who was going too close to shore and upsetting several neighbors.
We took it upon ourselves to reach out to him, let him know his actions were being perceived.
He was very apologetic, didn't know the operation was incorrect and appreciated the outreach.
There is no longer a problem on Patakawai Lake.
In New Hampshire, we can talk to each other, and as boaters, we need to continue our outreach to solve problems without legislation.
We do not need House Bill 1071.
It will create more problems than it solves.
Thank you for your time.
Thank you very much.
Is there any questions from the committee?
Seeing none, thank you very much.
In support of the bill, Susan Price.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman and members of the committee.
I am Susan Price, and I'm also the Fish and Game Commissioner for Carroll County.
We did not, as a commission, take a position on this bill.
It came to our attention yesterday, and so we were a little late to the party so the commission does not have a position but I had intended to testify based upon my personal experience as well so I did discuss the bill with the director of inland fisheries that, that's Diane Timmons.
And her concerns were twofold.
One was already mentioned, the hitchhikers in the ballast tanks.
Everything from milfoil to zebra mussels, those are the common ones.
But the other issue is, and I actually have an aerial photo of this, is direct habitat destruction.
When these boats are filled with their ballast tanks and pulled down, they can increase turbidity up to 10 feet in depth.
And so the suspended sediment can stay in the water depending upon the water body and a number of factors for quite some time and possibly cause negative impact to aquatic life.
I actually do have an aerial photo of a lake in Indiana where you can see the scarring from the wake boats in the shallower areas of the lake.
So those were her concerns.
We apologize for not bringing an official position to the table.
We lost our legal coordinator, Paul Sanderson, to retirement.
So we've been over there.
Everybody's wearing a little different hat right now, trying to keep up with the legislative session.
I personally, I live in Moultonboro, near the Tuftonboro line.
We slip a boat at Melvin Village Marina.
It's a powerboat.
It is, by most standards, quite fast.
It is a Lund fishing boat.
I am also a certified stand-up paddleboard instructor with the American Canoe Association.
So I enjoy the lake both as a paddler as well as a fisherman and a powerboat owner.
And I've had some very, what I feel are safety issues with wakeboard boats personally.
They do make a high amplitude, low frequency wave.
And these waves tend to sort of sneak up on you.
I would consider myself a very experienced paddleboarder.
I will typically paddle from Melvin Bay down to Wolfboro, have lunch, go over to Center Harbor.
I spend hours on the lake paddleboarding.
So I can take, personally, I can take these type of waves.
But I can't give an instruction, I can't give a lesson on Lake Winnipesaukee to a beginner.
And I do see people in kayaks, on paddle boards, also small fishing craft, like shorter 12-foot single-haul boats, small horsepower.
These wake boats have created wakes that break over the bow of their boat.
So I do support personally an increase in the setback due to my personal experience on the lake.
Regarding my powerboat, it is it's rigged for fishing, or the one I had before the one I have now.
How many boats do I own?
That's my salesman.
So I don't know if you're familiar with a trolling motor.
You typically mount them on the bow of the boat, and you deploy them when you want to maintain a fishing position.
And the newer trolling motors are all GPSed, so you can maintain your your position in one spot I have had a wakeboat outside of the 150 rule I'm there they're in compliance but their wake the amplitude of that wake is so great that I have a 60 inch bow on my depth and the trolling motor will be lifted out of the water and cavitate in the air so I do see a need because these boats have a specific purpose that causes a specific type of wave I do see a need from a safety standpoint for an increased setback I personally enjoy watching the wakeboats.
I think it's fun to watch people that are substantially younger and fitter than I do these aerobatics and stuff.
I'm not anti-wakeboat.
But my personal experience leads me to believe that there are people in other craft that have safety issues, and there's just a need to increase that safety buffer for those paddlers and the smaller craft out there.
So I'd be happy to take any questions.
Thank you.
Is there any questions by members of the committee?
Any other questions?
Thank you.
Is there already a buffer that needs to be observed between a boat and a person in the water?
That would be the 150-foot rule.
It's against any craft, any dock, basically any person, anything.
The other thing that comes to mind as well, getting more to the habitat destruction.
Winnipesaukee is like a lot of smaller lakes within one big lake.
And I think people who don't spend time on this lake don't understand that If you look at a chart of the lake the Moultonboro Tuftonboro part of the lake tends to be very narrow we have some large bays but when you get up into the the greens basin area the There are some loon habitat and the wakeats in there, they have had problems with the, not specifically tied to the wakeboats, but the loon, some of the loon nests have been washed out.
And I could see some of these waves potentially having a loon impact.
I have no evidence of that.
But my personal experience knowing where the loon nests are on that part of the lake, I could see it happening out of the Lees Mill area.
And I did bring a handout.
I'd be glad to send a link to this of the aerial photo of the lake in Indiana showing the vegetative scarring from the wake boats.
Any other questions from members of the committee?
Seeing none, thank you very much for your testimony.
And if you have anything you want to send to the committee besides this, we appreciate it.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Kim Bonifant, in opposition to the bill?
She's not here?
Oh, okay.
That's fine.
Still on the...
I'll go for another person who's in opposition to the bill.
Scott Fitzgerald.
Good afternoon, everybody.
I appreciate your time.
My name is Scott Fitzgerald.
I'm a resident of New London.
Good afternoon, everybody.
I appreciate your time.
My name is Scott Fitzgerald.
I'm a resident of New London, New Hampshire.
Like a few others here, I actually rent a slip on Lake Sunapee.
That's the main where we have a wake surf boat in opposition to this.
I say in opposition.
I am in appreciation of the bill of the dialogue of the attempt to collaborate in a way to try and share the lakes I Would just add I'm not going to belabor the points that have already been made as time sensitive here I think a couple of points to make to add on In terms of the depth that wake surfers use, wake surfers actually avoid shallow water.
If you're going in 20 feet of water and all of a sudden you dip to 8 feet of water, your wave becomes basically unsurfable because of the ability of the boat to propel the water at a depth that would create a wave that size.
So that doesn't mean everybody, but I would say the vast majority of wake surfers will avoid shallow areas because it's actually antithetical to what they're trying to do, which is surf.
I would say as an educator, I guess I made a choice to become an educator, but there's an economic impact that probably will inhibit my ability to ever have a house on a lake and I know that is a choice but I think this dialogue has to be sensitive to the ability to share the waterways for people who have the ability to purchase a home on the lake and those who don't whether that's by choice or not by choice and that's how do we share I guess I go default to the educator's mindset on how do we properly share.
If I'm a member of a rowing committee, a rowing club, a wake surf boat is kryptonite basically to my existence so I can understand the emotional response to that as they're trying to enjoy the lake just as we are.
I think there's other ways to do that, because regulation will then inhibit some people's abilities to access these lakes.
And I don't think that's a good thing.
I think we can find ways to educate.
We can find ways to share.
We can use time.
We often wake surf for sunrise.
And I can tell you, at 530 in the morning in the summer, there's not a lot of people there and we have open waters we stay in the middle we try to not pass over houses but I do understand that my coincidentally my slip is in a no-wake zone and I'll probably never rent one outside of a no wake zone so I am very sensitive to all types of craft that sit on a dock or on on and waves have a significant impact on that how they're tied one big wave can cause extensive damage to a boat and I'm very sensitive to that so again how do we cooperate rather than I think over regulation will limit use and I think that's what I grew up in New Hampshire and chose to come back to New Hampshire.
One of my favorite things about New Hampshire is the ability to have dialogue.
I'm an athletic director at a high school, so I kind of swim, pun intended, in emotion and dialogue and how do you approach things and how do you regulate versus how do you cooperate.
I think we also need to understand that many of us and many boaters choose there is 150 but we choose you have the ability to go more and many do choose that we try in schools and I think as lawmakers you try to do the same you don't try to regulate based on anomalies there are anomalies that tourists and residents alike that will abuse their privilege to use the water.
They will have zero consideration of others.
And I'd be naive to say I have the silver bullet answer to address that.
But I just would say I'm sensitive to the issue.
I'm sensitive to both sides.
but I don't think overregulation in this instance is the way because it limits access.
It limits people's ability to share the water.
How do we work as a team to go about enjoying these waterways collectively and together as a state?
Thank you.
Is there any member of the committee who has a question?
Seeing representative folks.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair, and thank you for coming to testify today.
You said you have a wakeboat or a boat that you use for wake surfing.
Yes.
And I wondered, the past speaker was talking about the water in the ballast.
Can you tell me about what you do with that water?
And a gentleman, I believe it was John, referenced it earlier in terms of how you fill it.
And that's, again, like a bass boat as well.
You're going to fill your tanks.
And so most wake surfers will begin the process of going out to the middle.
And while you're in that process, you fill up.
So you are away from shore traveling to an area where you can start surfing.
Basically, you travel to where you can begin surfing.
So you're not riding shore.
You're not going shallow.
Again, we don't want any of the areas churned up.
I have that dock that we rent, and we want to sustain that area as well.
So we go out to the middle where there's enough water to do that.
Second?
For an additional question.
Thank you.
Whoops, sorry.
So generally when you're going back to shore or going back to your dock, you allow the water to go out slowly as you're coming into shore.
Is that how that works?
We do, yeah.
Actually, we get somewhat near the no-wake zone, which I see many do, because, again, with all that weight, you're not going to want to maintain that weight as you're pulling in your dock.
The vast majority of docks are not deep-water docks, so you're coming in to 6, 8, 10 feet.
So you're not going to want that boat to sink in the water as you're pulling in the dock.
So we make sure we empty it out well advance because not only do we want that water away from shore but we also don't want to increase the ability for our boat to be damaged because it's weighed down as we get close to shore I was gonna ask you do you ever take your boat out to another lake, or do you primarily ski on the lake you're at?
I do not.
That boat that I have, the total weight is about 6,500 pounds.
I am quite nervous to move that thing.
I take it from the marina once a year, put it in the water, and then take it back.
And I think the mere size of the boat really kind of prohibits many from doing that I think people try to categorize it in the same way they do a bass fishing boat where you're going to the tournament and I had one of those you're constantly pulling that in and out and that's where invasive species come in exponentially and exponentially higher rate but the they're so big that they're not necessarily going to be pulled out.
Thank you very much.
Any other questions from members of the committee?
Seeing none.
Thank you very much.
Thank you for your time.
Thank you.
Now from someone in support of the bill, Dan McCaffrey.
Now from someone in support of the bill, Dan McCaffrey, Spindle Point Association.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman, committee.
My name is Dan McCaffrey.
I've been living in Meredith for 22 years now.
I'd also like to let you know that I am the president of the Spindle Point Association.
Spindle Point is located on the peninsula that forms the eastern side of the mouth to Meredith Bay and it separates Meredith Bay from Cummings Cove, just to give you a little geographical reference.
I'm an average boater, including water sports.
I'm here in support of the bill.
I'm hoping that this bill is the start of a process that becomes a compromise between wake boaters, paddlers, sailboat folks, as well as just recreational boaters and fishermen.
A little bit about the science that's been mentioned here to date.
We talked about amplitude and low-frequency waves, But I, it bears mentioning how the lake bed affects the waves.
When you have a, like any wave, you go to the ocean, you see the waves crashing on the beach.
If it's a gradual seafloor, the waves will break gradually.
if the seafloor rises up sharply like it does in a lot of glacier lakes, which is Lake Winnipesaukee and many other lakes in New Hampshire, the wave crashes dramatically.
So what's happened over the last few years with the popularity of wake boats, especially in my neighborhood, which represents 110 waterfront homes in Merida.
Depending upon the geography of the lot, these waves from boats crash directly on the shoreline, which is oftentimes rocky, or even premature to the shoreline.
So it's crashing in like one or two feet before it gets to the shore.
So what are the results of that?
From a habitat standpoint, over the 22 years that I've been here in Meredith, we have traditionally had in the late spring between 15 and 18 fish nests.
Seen fish nests before?
The fish make a small circle in the sand, lay their eggs?
Well, this year, due to the wave action, the typical 15 to 18 fish nests that you can see while standing on my dock were gone by the end of June.
All gone.
One survived.
Now, I'm not a biologist like one of the gentlemen from DES who testified, but I don't know what the impact is or is going to be for the, say, 15 fish nests that are gone and what those small fish mean to the trout they were going to eat them or the bass or the salmon.
The other effect of the wave action that we have specifically in Winnipesaukee and in Cummings Cove is the inability for others to enjoy the lake.
Mentioned earlier, we have wakeboarders, we have recreational boaters, fishermen, paddlers, sailors.
My wife specifically will not go out kayaking if she can't go out in the morning and be back by 7 a.m.
due to the wave action.
A bit on a little more on the erosion effect.
It's been mentioned here that it's not just waves that create erosion.
Again, not a scientist, and I can absolutely agree that ice and rock movement can have an effect.
But you really have to look back at the history and realize in the 90s when it was codified for distance from the shore, it was recognized that waves do have a cause and effect.
Voluntarily, the marine industry here has suggested to people, let's go to 200.
Voluntarily, the law codified at 150.
This bill is asking for 250.
There were many that could argue that it should be much farther off from shore.
At least the passing of this bill will start that process.
There are many that could argue that it should be much farther off, I'm sure.
You can stand on my dock and watch the erosion.
When the waves come in, they destroy the fishnests because of the amplitude.
The waves crash and fall on top of themselves as they come into the shore.
I have irreparable erosion on my property and in many of my neighbors.
So what is the irony here?
We have a state law, Shore Land Protection Act, very well codified, that sets out all types of rules and regulations for what I need to do to protect the natural shoreline, the vegetation, the trees, the blueberry bushes.
Right?
However, the shoreline is being destroyed from the other side.
And I can watch it.
And we all know cause and effect.
Big waves cause erosion.
Look at the news.
Ask anyone who lives on Cape Cod.
The New Jersey hurricane, houses falling into the ocean.
Waves cause damage.
We have to mitigate that.
So I encourage you to pass this as a part of a process.
Let's move forward to getting a good community of people that can enjoy the lake, all people of all different boating types and personalities.
Thank you very much for your testimony.
Any questions by members of the committee?
Seeing none, thank you very much.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
In opposition to the bill is Evan Goldner.
I am the owner and operator of a small water sports summer camp called Water Monkey in the Lakes region.
My primary business is teaching kids at the summer camp wakeboarding, water skiing, and wake surfing.
I also offer private lessons on my lake, on other people's boats, on my boats, in all those sports, plus more and more on boat driving as well.
People will call and say, you know, we have this boat.
We don't know how to drive it, how to trailer it, how to do this, and I'll spend as long as they want working with them on driving the boat.
I'm here to oppose HB 1071 and the proposed 250-foot setback for wake surf boats.
I believe this new rule would limit where the wake surfing is possible in our state and would reduce access to this sport.
I never was lucky enough to have a lake house.
I always, always, always wanted to be on the water.
So when I finished college and I was freshly out, I was like, I need to be on the water back in New Hampshire.
I thought of this idea for this camp, and I started it, and I'm out there having fun every day.
And I'm really fortunate that in the scope of running this business, I've spent thousands of hours driving wakeboard boats, inboard, outboards, every kind of boat you can imagine.
People call me, they're like, I've got an aluminum fishing boat, my kids want to water ski.
I will be there helping them water ski.
So I'm super lucky to travel the state doing this.
I do this on my lake, as well as other lakes, ponds, and rivers around New Hampshire.
In this capacity, I have a unique perspective into the water sports pursuits of families, groups, individuals, and businesses.
Wake surfing has really revolutionized how people of all ages and abilities, I think that's really important, and I'll get to that, and demographics have fun on the water and enjoy the outdoors.
So briefly, the range of people I have introduced wake surfing to is really incredible.
I'll speak about three groups that I think really benefit from wake surfing.
First are men and women in their 60s, 70s, and 80s.
I get so many calls from people who were like, you know, I water skied my entire life.
Now, you know, shoulders, hips, knees can't handle the motion of getting up out of the water.
Whereas wake surfing, that's not a problem for them.
And it's really fun to see these people, you know, get behind the boat, get up, and just immediate joy and fun.
It's so awesome to see.
And they share that with their grandkids.
It's really fun.
Next group are little kids.
A lot of little kids, I'm talking like four, five, six, they're nervous to be behind the boat water skiing and wakeboarding and they don't really have that feeling with wake surfing.
We're going much slower.
We can be in the seat in the back of the boat talking them through every step.
And it's just so, again, amazing to see little kids just pop up and their parents are like, we never thought that would happen so quickly.
That's really fun.
The last group that I think is so important are kids and adults with physical, mental, and emotional disabilities.
I've worked with so many different people where way back on a water ski line, they might struggle, they might not have the strength or be missing part of a limb.
They cannot water ski or wakeboard, whereas wake surfing, we can adapt how we teach it.
There's different ways you can get up.
There's different ways to teach things.
You can overcome these limitations.
Wake surfing is also super interactive, easily demonstrated, so people who learn differently can pick it up quickly.
It's just such a unique sport in that aspect that aspect.
Lots of people I teach use their wake surf boats on smaller water bodies.
I do lessons on the Merrimack River.
If this bill were to pass with 250-foot setback, most of the Merrimack River you could not wake surf anymore.
It's narrow.
It's super long.
We always stay in the middle.
We go right down the middle.
But 250 feet on either side, that's cutting off.
Anyone that wants to boat on Merrimack would not be able to wake surf there.
And that would be a shame because people love these sports.
For over a decade, as wake surfing has exploded, I mean, I was there at the beginning doing this.
People would come up next to our boat and be like, what are you doing?
We're wake surfing.
This is awesome.
And we would educate people.
And that's what my career is all about, that teaching people about these sports, having fun, being safe on the water.
I've witnessed wake surf boats coexist with other motorized and non-motorized watercraft and swimmers and property owners and the wildlife.
And I really don't think it would be productive to pass a rule that just targets one activity I'm happy to take any questions you guys have about wake surfing boating summer camps anything you've got any any questions by members of the committee.
Representative.
Questions by members of the committee?
Representative Pouss, go ahead.
Do you have a camp schedule for the over 60 crowd?
We do.
We do it all the time.
Private lessons, it's super fun.
I have people out there all the time.
Representative Egan.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you, sir, for taking my question.
How do you schedule your training of students in the water knowing that you can't schedule when wake surfing boats will come by, especially working with younger children that are new to the water?
Great question.
It's not really a problem we've ever had.
I teach people from sunrise to sunset every day on every kind of water body.
I've never had to stop a lesson for a certain kind of boat.
I've had bad boaters come really close, really dangerous, and that's going to happen with any kind of boat.
Usually not wake boats.
Wake boats are pretty expensive.
People want to drive better.
When I work with new families that buy boats, they're so receptive to my critiques, my input, and how they drive, which is really cool.
So I've never had to stop a lesson working with kids, adults, for any kind of boat traffic or anything.
Sure.
Anyone else?
Seeing none, thank you very much.
Thank you.
We have now a friend in support My name is Larry Briggs, and I'm lucky enough to have a home on Lake Sunapee in New Hampshire.
And as a homeowner, I've personally observed the oversized waves that come from wake surfing and the impact that those oversized waves have not only on the shorelines, structures such as docks, boats tied to docks.
I think you've heard that from others here today.
And more importantly, on the grandchildren, my grandchildren, I'm lucky to have four, that oftentimes will play in the shallows.
These waves will knock you right over.
As a trained engineer, I strive to follow the data and the science.
I personally have found the University of Minnesota study to be comprehensive and note that it was peer-reviewed by subject matter experts.
And I urge the committee to support HB 1071 and also to amend the standoff distance.
I'm all in favor of increasing it to 500 feet.
There's room for all.
I'll be happy to answer any questions.
Any questions by members of the committee?
Seeing none, thank you very much.
In opposition to the bill is Tanya Knightley.
I have lived on Pleasant Lake in Northwood for over 20 years.
I care deeply about the health of the lake.
My husband is on the Lake Association Board of Directors.
My sons grew up on the lake, and I hope someday I'll have grandchildren who will enjoy the sport on the lake as well.
Wake surfing is one of many activities we enjoy on Pleasant Lake, and it is by far the most engaging for my sons and their friends.
It is one of the few activities that can pull them away from a computer screen.
But I did not come here today merely as a mom trying to keep a sport her children love.
I am also a volunteer adaptive sports instructor with a non-profit group affiliated with the University of New Hampshire called Northeast Passage.
I teach people with disabilities how to adapt water sports so they can enjoy some of the same pastimes that we take for granted.
It is more than just having fun on the water for people with disabilities.
It is also about overcoming challenges and having a sense of accomplishment when their world is filled with obstacles.
In my 16 years as an instructor, I have had many tearful moms express their gratitude for making it possible for their child to be just like other kids.
One young lady told me how when she woke up in the hospital after her accident, she was devastated.
She made a list of all the things she would never be able to do.
But after seeing what she was capable of doing behind a boat, she planned to cross all those items off her list.
Most of the boats we use at Northeast Passage are wakeboats, because they are versatile and work well at different speeds and wake sizes.
The configuration allows family and friends to be part of the experience without getting in the way of safety personnel and equipment on the boat.
There are people today proposing restrictions to wakeboats that will severely impact our ability to work with disabled athletes.
Mobility issues can make it hard to transfer people from water to boat so often we start and end close to shore to allow for an assisted swim to shore deep water instruction and starts are harder to perform and less safe for both our instructors and our students the increased distance we would need to maintain from our support vehicles would create issues with communication, increase the time to get to a disabled participant, and increase anxiety for some of our participants, especially those with visual and hearing impairments.
These restrictions could make it impossible for us to teach some of our most vulnerable participants.
And for this reason, I you please don't pass this bill because I am on the lake all the time I see the good the bad and the ugly inconsiderate and dangerous operators are not limited to one kind of boat or water sport I've seen a bay liner run at top speed through three clearly marked buoys and end up on the rocks.
I've watched boats filled with people towing multiple children on one tube, circling round and round, creating huge waves to the detriment of others until heads collide and children fly.
It would be harmful to single out and punish one group.
A huge effort was made last year to educate wakeboat operators on best practices when pulling a wake surfer.
And last summer, I could see the difference on our lake.
Let's continue down the road of education instead of setting restrictions aimed at destroying the sport and the industry that serves it.
Thank you very much for your time.
Any questions by members of the committee?
Seeing none, thank you very much.
In support of the bill, Gary York.
Gary York.
Let's see.
Not here.
Then, for someone else in support of the bill, Carl Lair, Luger.
If that's the way you say it.
Nobody other, no other Carl stood up, so I guess it's you from Holderness.
Okay.
Turn on your – there you are.
Turn on the red light.
Chair, members of the committee, I appreciate the opportunity to speak to you today.
I've had the good fortune to have been living on Squam Lake for 15 years now, and we have a place on the lake that is on a cove that is well appreciated by water skiers.
And I have seen many water skiers come back and forth through the area.
But in the last couple of years, we've seen a lot of these wave, wake surfing boats.
And that has changed our market, our waterfront significantly.
We have a floating dock because we have many, many canoes and kayaks.
I think at last count there's three canoes, six or seven whitewater kayaks, and about maybe nine flatwater kayaks.
But no more boats.
I hate internal combustion engines.
But having a floating dock makes it much easier to get in and out of those boats.
But the wake boats have really changed the equation.
and I am no longer able to walk on my dock when there are wakeboats going around our cove because it bounces the dock around so much that I can no longer stand up straight safely.
And that's very frustrating for me.
I thought I'd just make a few other comments.
What effect might wake boats have on other lake users?
The most obvious is the generation of large waves, which they do well.
It's something that these boats were created for in the first place.
These large waves, however, are created where there are no such natural waves.
The unexpected waves can surprise or even capsize boaters, especially those in small boats such as kayaks and canoes.
And as I said, it can even surprise people on floating docks when they find their dock is no longer stable.
The waves resulting from wake boats passing through an area are unusual because they have a shorter wavelength, which means they may come closer together.
They are steeper, which means they hit the shore, docks, swimmers, and other things harder.
They come from different directions from normal wind-created waves.
As a result, people can be surprised because the waves are not the way a normal wind-driven wave would be to them.
And I've tried to get into kayaks and canoes sometimes when I misjudged when a wave was going to come to us, and it would come close to capsizing at my dock, which is something I'd rather not do.
The thing about wake boats is that they cannot legislate away from having big waves.
That's the whole purpose behind those boats.
Although I have learned just in the last few days that they can have some influence about where those waves are directed, and I'm delighted to see that happen.
The last thing that concerns me is that the wake boats will stir up the water and thus the sediment and have the possibility of freeing up nutrients that is currently within the sediments and giving more food for cyanobacteria blooms, which is something I'm sure most everyone in this room knows and would like to avoid very assiduously.
And so I'm just cautious about anything that would give cyanobacteria a foothold.
So I would request that you vote for the HB 1071.
I think it would give all boat users a chance at using the state's lake assets.
but because in many places canoes and kayaks are simply not feasible to be used when you're in close proximity to a wakeboat, I think that we have to allow some places where wakeboats are not allowed so that the canoes and kayaks have some safe places to play as well.
Thank you.
I'll be happy to play as well.
I'd be happy to answer any questions that anyone may have.
Is there any member of the committee who has a question?
Seeing none, thank you very much.
Ryan Laliberti, or Laliberti, if you have a name like mine.
Is there a Ryan?
And which pronunciation is it?
Laliberti.
Laliberti?
Okay.
Hi, my name is Ryan La Liberty.
I'm 11 years old and I learned how to wake surf four years ago.
I oppose House Bill 1071 and these are the reasons why.
Wake surfing is my favorite thing to do in the summer.
My whole family does it and we spend time together wake surfing.
Thank you.
and these are the reasons why.
Wake surfing is my favorite thing to do in the summer.
My whole family does it, and we spend time together wake surfing.
And my 7-year-old little brother just learned how to wake surf, and now he wants to do it all the time.
Before he learned, he spent too much time on his iPad or watching TV and not outside.
I get to spend time with my family wake surfing on weekends in the summer and we can even go to the lake after school and work for a few hours.
I went to water monkey camp last year and I loved it.
I want to go again this summer.
My little brother says he wants to do it when he's old enough.
House bill 1071 would limit where I can wake surf.
Please don't pass this bill.
Everyone should try wake surfing at least once.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Is there any questions from members of the committee?
Of course.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair, and thank you, Ryan, for taking my question.
Thank you for coming.
You are the future of New Hampshire.
What do you think would be a great way to educate people on the proper use of wakeboats?
I don't really know.
What have you learned about the proper use of wakeboats that you could share with the committee so we know how you're learning?
I have a lot of family members that have taught me how to wakesurf.
And we go, we visit a lot of places where they teach us how to wakesurf.
And also on the boat, you learn about the boat and the proper techniques.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Again, I really appreciate you and your wife bringing your child here to testify, and I can't thank you guys enough for understanding the process and getting them involved in it.
It's really, like Representative Maybill said, you are the future of our state, and we appreciate you being here, and you, the lady, as well.
Thank you.
Anyone else?
Thank you very much.
Thank you for appearing before the committee.
Now you've got to clean that off.
Brett Nigro.
Thank you.
My name is Brett Nigro.
I live year-round on Coppets Pond in Wyndham, New Hampshire, in Rockingham County.
Thank you for your time today.
There's been a lot of testimony, so most of my script is out the window, and I'm just going to give you the cliff notes for everyone's benefit.
Over the past 12 years, I've served as a board of directors member on my lake association, and two of which I served as our president.
I am here today speaking for myself, but I do bring many of you from residents on my lake to the table today.
I guess I represent the little guys, the little lakes.
We are 345 acres in a figure eight configuration, long and narrow, if you will, with a no-wake zone in the middle and two small ponds on either side.
As a result, this bill, if passed as constituted, would be detrimental to the wake surfing sport on Cobbett's Pond, which is quite robust.
There are more than 20 wake surf boats on our lake today, all of which owned by family members, and it is the quintessential family sport, as many here have talked about today, so I won't get into those details.
What I would like to say is that the sport is relatively young, and with anything new, you're going to have your hiccups and speed bumps, and there's a learning curve associated with it, and I think the Wake Responsibility Program is a great step forward in the education of people on how to more responsibly use these powerful boats for the betterment of everyone and the enjoyment of the users, but also in respect for our neighbors.
And the common theme here that I've heard is usually in support of people that reside in these large bodies of water, where it seems maybe it's a no-brainer to extend.
What's 100 feet?
Well, in a lake like mine, it's detrimental.
It's punitive.
It pretty much will suffocate the ability to do so.
And frankly, I think it's premature for a bill at this time to be passed based on a University of Minnesota study, which frankly is inconclusive in my mind.
If you read the details, it's four boats, two surf boats, a recreational boat, and a competition ski boat.
A competition ski boat is designed specifically to skim across the top of the water and make no wave behind it whatsoever so that skiers at high speed can ski without any sort of obstruction.
When you amortize the data in a way that they did, it fits a certain narrative, and certain narrative is the reason that this bill is put in 40 today with an arbitrary 250 feet.
This at its core is an education issue, not a legislation issue in my opinion.
On our lake, we consistently preach situational awareness courtesy being alert as a driver understanding the cause of your actions when voting being short just being a good neighbor and I think that we as New Hampshire residents are more than capable of handling this issue with better education and if the state wants to get involved my suggestion is why don't we have a little more attention thrown towards the New Hampshire boater licensing process in that educational scenario in which we gloss over the good boating practices and focus way too much on ocean-going vessels for which a very small percentage of New Hampshire boats are registered.
The majority of New Hampshire boats are registered on lakes.
So why isn't there more focus on lakes?
Now that this sport has exploded and created a tremendous amount of demand to get into the sport, which frankly has also created real estate demand on lakefronts, which drove up property prices, which drove up tax income, revenue, and things along those lines, it's an important issue, and I know it's got the ear of some people, or the ire, I should say, of some people that kind of view it as an easy thing to point at as problems.
But in my opinion, if we segregate this sport at this point, it's premature.
There's not enough data to support it, and I think the community as a whole has rallied behind wanting to make it a safer and better place.
The 150-foot setback is just a guide.
Most folks, as has been testified here today, they seek the largest area of water possible and try to do so in a respectful way.
These boats aren't typically operated by young kids.
It's typically fathers like myself.
I'm super jealous of the families that brought their daughters with them here today.
My 14-year-old Bella was going to join me, an avid wake surfer, but she's currently at her middle school basketball playoff game, for which I'm missing to be here today, because I do feel it's that important for you guys to hear the perspective of a small lake property owner like myself.
In terms of education, if we could do something greater than what we're doing in the Wake Responsibility Program, I think we will be doing that.
Talk to folks with better knowledge of what's in store for that program and work on the boater education before people even get behind the wheel of the boat.
I think that's going to go a long way versus a premature segregation of the activity as a whole.
30 calls to Marine Patrol hardly warrants, in my opinion, a call to action to put legislation pieces in place at this time.
So I do appreciate you guys letting me speak here today, and I'm happy to answer any and all questions.
Actually, one last thing I would like to mention.
Two years back, we did host Senator Regina Birdsell on our wakeboats and gave her a thorough demonstration of how they operate and the waves themselves and spent a lot of time answering her questions.
And I'd open that up to anyone here on the committee or anyone on the opposition side as well if they'd like a firsthand view of how wakeboats work, how the actual sport works, how we can control waves, and best practices that we employ as an emerging sport.
So with that, I'm happy to answer any questions.
Any questions from members of the committee?
Representative Post.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair, and thank you for your unique perspective on licensing being a way to reach out to people to better educate them on their boating in lakes.
Since you are on a small lake with a very large population of wake boats, have you seen a lot of damage on your shoreline?
And if so, what type of damage is it?
So, you know, sitting on our lake committee, I'm privy to a lot of information.
We work hand-in-hand with the DES.
We work tirelessly with developers in our community, making sure that, you know, all the local legislation is upheld in terms of the development process.
With the 93 expansion, we experienced a ton of issues within our lake environment.
So I'm fairly well versed on the goings-on in that capacity.
And I can tell you that the waves generated from a specific type of activity is the least of our problems.
The freeze-thaw, as another gentleman mentioned, is a far bigger issue.
Just the general waves that are generated during a winter storm or a fall storm or any storm, winter, summer, whatever the season may be, that smashes repeatedly for three, four hours into a shoreline absolutely has bigger impacts than occasional rollers that come in from a wake circle.
I'm not saying it doesn't have an impact.
I'm sure it does in some capacity.
To what degree, I don't really know.
But I can tell you that we're all painfully aware of it.
We love what we do, but not at the detriment of our neighbors and our own property.
We're highly invested in the areas that we live, and everyone is very responsible.
Those that aren't, we do go out there and help self-police and say, hey, you were out of line, you drove improperly or whatever the case may be.
People are incredibly respectful of criticism.
You've got to remember, this is people's leisure time.
They're not out there for work.
They're out there to blow off steam.
We're all under a lot of stress and they're out there with their families.
No one's intentionally trying to be a bad driver, but driving up here in 93, I saw a bunch of bad drivers too.
Speed limit's 65 for everyone.
So I just think to take our little sport that's growing and bring a lot of joy to families and people in general and put it in a box at this early stage is not right.
A follow-up?
For a follow-up.
Thank you.
You're telling me that you haven't seen any noticeable deterioration of the shoreline since the increase in wakeboats?
Nothing I could measure for you.
I certainly have heard different people have spoken here today that make accusations.
But in my direct property, I can absolutely say with certainty that, yes, waves have come in, but I'm not complaining or thinking that that's the reason that whatever erosion we have is the primary cause.
Mother Nature by far has been more impactful to my property than any wave generated from a boat.
And I will say that some of the most egregious waves and disruptances on our lake aren't even from wake boats.
They're from tubers and people in other types of boats.
There's a gentleman with a hybrid boat that's a pontoon on top and has a traditional V-hole on the bottom and a powerful motor.
It's kind of a hybrid boat.
It's incredibly heavy, and it throws a tremendous amount of water at the shoreline, and he zips all over the place with a 45-foot line with his kids whipping back and forth, and no one's calling that type of boat out for a specific subset of rules.
So I really do think, taking a macro look at this, that if we can teach people to be good responsible boat drivers, all this other stuff is not necessary.
Let New Hampshire people do what New Hampshire people have always done and that's govern thyselves without the need for legislative impairment or impact.
Any other questions by members of the committee?
Well, seeing none, thank you very much.
This is, that was the last pink card before we go.
I'd like to thank the audience.
I'd like to thank everyone here.
It was a very good hearing.
And I especially would like to thank the parents who brought their children.
This is democracy, and you're showing it to them.
And by the way, we do have a tour of this place.
please take a look of this place.
Please take them.
This is the oldest state house still under use in the United States.
And you ought to take the tour.
And let your representative, state representative, know.
And probably that person will come and give you the tour themselves because we do have a thing when they bring the fourth graders in, and that's the best thing that any rep can do.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
I will call the hearing.
House Bill 1071.
Adjourned.
Oh, let me read the...
I've got to read the...
Read the...
We got...
I got to read the, read the, oh yeah, we got, we got a lot of people.
We got a lot of people.
Oh, by the way, what happened to the, what happened to the number?
Thank you.